So I'm here with Nick Russell, who probably has done more in his life than we can even include in an interview, let alone a preamble. But we're going to talk about two things. One, his new book, the second volume of James Hellman, The Jungian Analyst's Autobiography. And then also some stuff about shamanism, schizophrenia, the deep unconscious and Dick's relationship with his son and the book that he wrote about that. And we may get to some other stuff too, but those are probably pretty big topics. So thank you so much for being here. It's really exciting to talk to you. Hey, Joel, really glad to be with you today
我和尼克·拉塞尔（Nick Russell）在一起，他一生中做过的事情可能比我们能在采访中提到的还要多，更不用说开场白了。但我们要谈两件事。第一，他的新书，詹姆斯·希尔曼（James Hillman）传记的第二卷，《荣格分析师的自传》。然后还有一些关于萨满教、精神分裂症、深层潜意识、迪克（Dick）与他儿子的关系以及他为此写的书的内容。我们可能还会谈到其他一些事情，但这些已经是很大的话题了。所以非常感谢你能来。和你交谈真的很令人兴奋。嘿，乔尔，很高兴今天能和你在一起。
and meet you in person. Yeah, I guess first off, some people have probably are familiar with James Hellman, but we should give a little bit of a preamble about him. You know, he was a Jungian analyst that was very influential, especially in bringing Jungian ideas to America. And it wasn't that the Jungian ideas were not in America. It was that they were brought by kind of the New Age movement and the completely sapped of any meaning or a real connection to Jung, and I think Hillman brought a lot of, like, deaf psychology ideas to the U.S. in a way that was pretty pure and interesting and got, he was a lot of people's first experience with Jung. Kind of a rebel, you know, I think he probably didn't catch on as much in Europe because they're a little bit more uptight, especially British analysts were kind of always suspicious of him.
并亲自见到你。是的，我想首先，有些人可能熟悉詹姆斯·希尔曼，但我们应该对他做一个简短的介绍。你知道，他是一位非常有影响力的荣格分析师，特别是在将荣格思想引入美国方面。并不是说荣格思想在美洲不存在，而是它们被新时代运动引入，完全失去了任何意义或与荣格的真正联系。我认为希尔曼以一种相当纯粹和有趣的方式将许多深度心理学的思想带到了美国，这让很多人第一次接触到了荣格。他有点像个叛逆者，你知道，我认为他在欧洲可能没有那么受欢迎，因为他们有点保守，尤其是英国的分析师总是对他持怀疑态度。
And volume one of his autobiography came out a while ago, And I didn't realize until I was buying volume two last night that there's a volume three too. So this isn't even really going to be the end of it. I know. Yeah, it's a tome. But you know, I think he's worth it. I mean, he's been called, he was called this in a profile of him by the Connecticut newspaper a few years back. The wisest man you've probably never heard of. Oh, yeah. I saw that article. It's still online.
他的自传第一卷前段时间出版了，直到昨晚买第二卷时，我才意识到还有第三卷。所以这甚至还不是终点。我知道。是的，这是一部大部头。但你知道，我认为他值得。我的意思是，几年前康涅狄格州的一份报纸在对他进行的人物专访中称他为：你可能从未听说过的最聪明的人。哦，是的。我看到了那篇文章。它还在网上。
Yeah. Yeah. It's a great article. And, you know, I didn't ever intend to be his biographer. I'm not a psychologist per se. You know, I read a lot of Jung when I was younger and since. And my extended family had discovered Hillman's work in the 1990s. And we were reading him then at that time. He had just published The Soul's Code.
是的。是的。那是一篇很棒的文章。而且，你知道，我从来没打算成为他的传记作者。我本身不是心理学家。你知道，我年轻时读过很多荣格的书，后来也读过。我的大家庭在20世纪90年代发现了希尔曼的作品。那时我们正在读他的书。他刚刚出版了《灵魂密码》（The Soul's Code）。
That was his big claim to fame. He was. He was kind of regretting his career and bemoaning, you know, maybe burning some of the bridges he burned and saying that he didn't have a superannuation, you know, right when Soul's Code got him on the Oprah Winfrey show. That's right. Yeah, Oprah loved that book. And, of course, once you're on Oprah, it became the number one bestselling book in the country. Yeah, she could have had like the 1992 CRX Honda motorcycle guide to maintenance on her show. And it would have sold a million copies.
那是他成名的代表作。他当时有点后悔自己的职业生涯，哀叹自己可能烧毁了一些桥梁，并说他没有养老金，就在《灵魂密码》让他上了奥普拉·温弗瑞（Oprah Winfrey）的节目时。没错。是的，奥普拉很喜欢那本书。当然，一旦你上了奥普拉的节目，它就成了全国排名第一的畅销书。是的，她当时就算在节目里推荐1992年本田CRX摩托车维修指南，也能卖出一百万本。
Exactly. So, so yeah, that, that book made him pretty well known and, and it was, it was only the second book. He kind of,
正是如此。所以，是的，那本书让他变得非常出名，而且，那仅仅是他的第二本书。他有点……
well, not that his other books weren't popular, but he nominated for a Pulitzer prize for revisioning psychology back in the 1970s when he wrote that. Yeah. But the soul's Code was very accessible. And, you know, I write about it in volume three, actually, which is coming out in a couple of months.
好吧，并不是说他的其他书不流行，但他早在20世纪70年代写《重构心理学》（Revisioning Psychology）时就被提名为普利策奖候选人。是的。但《灵魂密码》非常通俗易懂。而且，你知道，我实际上在第三卷中写到了它，第三卷几个月后就会出版。
All three volumes are done. And, again, people might ask, what? This is a three-volume biography of this depth psychologist? What's that all about? And I can understand that. But not only do I like to write these kind of in-depth tomes, I've written 15 books altogether, and some of them are pretty damn long, for better or for worse, right? But I feel like he is one of the greatest thinkers that
所有三卷都完成了。而且，人们可能会问，什么？这是一部关于这位深度心理学家的三卷本传记？这到底是怎么回事？我能理解。但我不喜欢写这种深度大部头，我总共写了15本书，其中一些确实非常长，不管好坏，对吧？但我认为他是我们有史以来最伟大的思想家之一。
we've ever had. Thomas More, the theologian and also bestselling author, said that, and he knew Hillman very well. Yeah, it's kind of hard to know where to start. I think I should probably start with how I came to write this book, don't you? I mean, it was a very unusual thing for me to take on. Did he know that you were going to write his autobiography? Did he give you his blessing or permission, or did family do that? that well he did once but but not admit well here's the story initially we we got to know each other and it's not an autobiography by the way it's a biography i mean i interviewed you know dozens of people about him and and he fully called an autobiography i'm sorry i misspoke that's okay you know i mean they're close but uh and and
神学家兼畅销书作家托马斯·摩尔（Thomas More）说过，他非常了解希尔曼。是的，很难知道从哪里开始。我想我应该从我是如何写这本书开始，你不觉得吗？我的意思是，对我来说，承担这件事是一件非常不寻常的事情。他知道你要写他的自传吗？他给你祝福或许可了吗，还是他的家人这么做的？好吧，他确实给过一次，但不是……好吧，故事是这样的，最初我们互相认识，顺便说一下，这不是自传，是传记。我的意思是，我采访了数十个关于他的人，他完全称之为自传，抱歉，我说错了。没关系，你知道，我的意思是它们很接近，而且……
there's a lot of his writings in the book and letters and all of that which make it almost autobiographical. But I had gotten to know him initially in kind of a strange way. We were reading him, as I say. And one day in the kitchen of my house when I was living in Boston, and the old man had grown up in our extended family, we were talking about Hillman, and he said, oh, my dad knows james hillman
书里有很多他的著作和信件，这使它几乎成了自传。但我最初是以一种奇怪的方式认识他的。正如我所说，我们在读他的书。有一天，在我住在波士顿的房子的厨房里，那位老人是在我们的大家庭中长大的，我们正在谈论希尔曼，他说，哦，我爸爸认识詹姆斯·希尔曼。
he sells him his organic vegetables in the market in connecticut i said oh wow henry really i did that's uh you think i'd be able to meet him sometime i'm so interested in his ideas and and uh he said so he gave i called his father it was an organic farmer he had a good old friend of mine and uh he said well well, you know, James Hilton's a very private person, you know, so I don't know, but he arranged a lunch anyway. And my wife and I went there and met with him and with my friend, Wayne Hanson, who was the introduction for us. And it kind of began, it was a friendship that began that day. He was 21 years older than I, so we weren't contemporaries really, but we both had common interests, including not in psychology.
他在康涅狄格州的市场上卖有机蔬菜给他。我说，哦，哇，亨利，真的吗？我做到了。那是……你觉得我什么时候能见到他吗？我对他的想法很感兴趣，他说……所以他给了我，我给他的父亲打了电话，他是一位有机农民，是我的一位好朋友，他说，好吧，你知道，詹姆斯·希尔曼是一个非常注重隐私的人，所以我不知道，但他还是安排了一顿午餐。我和我妻子去了那里，见到了他，还有我的朋友韦恩·汉森（Wayne Hanson），他为我们做了介绍。那段友谊就是从那天开始的。他比我大21岁，所以我们并不是同代人，但我们都有共同的兴趣，包括心理学之外的。
We talked about how we both spent time, a lot of time in Africa when we were young, just traveling around. And then he was a big fan of boxing, interestingly, which I had gotten to know Muhammad Ali at one point in my life. And so we kind of just connected on these other levels. And then he visited us in our homes. We had homes in a couple of different parts of the country, a group of people that I've been living with for a long time. And he loved the way we lived. You had a communal living situation for a while, didn't you?
我们谈到了我们年轻时都在非洲度过了很多时间，只是四处旅行。有趣的是，他还是个拳击迷，我生命中曾一度认识穆罕默德·阿里（Muhammad Ali）。所以我们在这些层面上建立了联系。然后他拜访了我们家。我们在全国几个不同的地方都有房子，那是一群我长期生活在一起的人。他很喜欢我们的生活方式。你有一段时间是集体生活，对吧？
Am I making that up? No, you're not making it up. I still do live that way cool he was very interested in that uh because we've been living together for so long and and and we you know we had these lovely houses we've created a very very successful construction company but it was more the feeling of community that he always uh admired and longed for and was part of in his own life. Collaborations were really hugely important to him. So he and his wife, Margo, visited us a number of times. And then that went on for a few years.
我是编出来的吗？不，你没编。我依然那样生活。酷。他对那个很感兴趣，因为我们在一起生活了这么久，而且，你知道，我们有这些可爱的房子，我们创建了一家非常非常成功的建筑公司，但他总是钦佩并渴望那种社区感，而且他自己生活中也是其中的一部分。合作对他来说非常重要。所以他和他的妻子玛戈（Margo）多次拜访我们。这种情况持续了几年。
And then at the end of 2004, I think it was, his older sister was visiting in Connecticut. And we went up there. I went up there for a visit over the Christmas holidays and she was telling all these stories about how he was growing up years in Atlantic City right and and the boardwalk when it was the heyday of it of all of that in the 1920s and there was something about Hellman that never got away from the boardwalk I mean he he still was kind of a carnival barker in the way that he brought his personality to the world.
然后在2004年底，我想是这样，他的姐姐在康涅狄格州探亲。我们去了那里。我在圣诞假期期间去那里拜访，她讲了所有关于他在大西洋城长大的故事，还有20世纪20年代木板路的全盛时期。希尔曼身上有一种永远无法摆脱木板路的东西，我的意思是，他把自己的个性带到世界上时，依然有点像个嘉年华的叫卖者。
He was a brilliant, brilliant guy. There still was a little bit of kind of almost a grifter type soap with a prize in it language that he probably liked. Well, he did. He grew up in this amazing fantasy world of, you know, of all these performers,
他是一个非常非常聪明的人。他身上依然带有一点点那种几乎是骗子式的、带有奖品的语言，他可能很喜欢。好吧，他确实喜欢。他在这个令人惊叹的幻想世界中长大，你知道，所有这些表演者，
the trapeze artists and so on that performed on the boardwalk. And his family owned a hotel there called The Breakers. And that's where he was born. He was born in a hotel room in 1926, actually. It was a Jewish family. Yes. And one grandfather on the other side of his family was a very famous rabbi, Joseph Krauskopf, a reform rabbi, interestingly. Not conventional at all, just like James Hillman was not conventional.
空中飞人等等，都在木板路上表演。他的家人在那里拥有一家名为“破浪者”（The Breakers）的酒店。他就是在那儿出生的。他实际上出生于1926年的一个酒店房间里。这是一个犹太家庭。是的。他家族另一边的一位祖父是一位非常有名的拉比，约瑟夫·克劳斯科普夫（Joseph Krauskopf），有趣的是，他是一位改革派拉比。一点也不传统，就像詹姆斯·希尔曼一样不传统。
And he told me, this was all in volume one, but he talked to me about how he used to go down into the basement, right? And he loved hanging out with the workers in the hotel, observing how they did things. And so he grew up in this fascinating milieu and got to know all kinds of interesting people that his parents had. You have these beautiful descriptions in the first volume that are almost would be better served in a novel about, you know, the Africanman contemplating the deep unconscious is probably sitting on the boardwalk watching these nets of of wriggling beasts being writhed out of the depths and he starts wondering what's inside of himself exactly it's a beautiful almost lovecraftian way to to build setting um in a biography which is not what you expect with out of a biography
他告诉我，这都在第一卷里，但他跟我谈到他过去常去地下室，对吧？他喜欢和酒店的工人们待在一起，观察他们做事的方式。所以他在这种迷人的环境中长大，认识了他父母认识的各种有趣的人。你在第一卷中有这些美丽的描述，几乎更适合小说，关于，你知道，非洲人凝视着深层潜意识，可能正坐在木板路上看着这些从深处扭动出来的蠕动野兽的网，他开始想知道自己内心深处有什么。没错，这是一种美丽的、几乎是洛夫克拉夫特式的构建背景的方式，在传记中，这不是你对传记的期望。
oh thank you yeah the deep sea net holes they called him right and uh and anyway his sister was talking when she was there in 2004 about those years and growing up in that family and he had three siblings and and uh i told him afterwards i said you know god she's older than he and i think you should really capture these uh on tape while she's still alive because they're great stories and so this this gave him the idea to bring his siblings and as many of his kids as could come together that summer. And a young filmmaker that was also grown up in my family, my extended family, came in and filmed the weekend. An old friend of his, Kenny Donahue, came from Ireland. And it was a marvelous weekend, lots of great food and everything in Connecticut.
哦，谢谢。是的，他们称之为深海网洞，对吧？无论如何，他的姐姐在2004年去那里时谈到了那些岁月以及在那个家庭中长大的经历，他有三个兄弟姐妹，我事后告诉他，我说，你知道，天哪，她比他大，我认为你应该在他还活着的时候把这些录下来，因为它们是伟大的故事。所以这让他想到了在那个夏天把他的兄弟姐妹和他尽可能多的孩子聚在一起。一位也在我的大家庭中长大的年轻电影制作人进来拍摄了那个周末。他的一位老朋友肯尼·多纳休（Kenny Donahue）从爱尔兰赶来。那是一个美妙的周末，在康涅狄格州有许多很棒的食物和一切。
And in the course of that, I'm an investigative reporter, right? So I started asking a lot of questions. And afterwards, our wives, Margo and Alice, got together and were having a glass of wine. And I think Alice asked, was James ever going to do a biography? And Margo said, you know, he's never wanted to do that. But anyway, he said, if anybody is going to do it, he'd like me to do it. Partly because I didn't have, I think, because I didn't have an ax to grind. I wasn't a psychologist with, you know, all these ideas and concepts about the field.
在此过程中，我是一名调查记者，对吧？所以我开始问很多问题。事后，我们的妻子玛戈和爱丽丝（Alice）聚在一起喝了一杯酒。我想爱丽丝问，詹姆斯会写传记吗？玛戈说，你知道，他从来不想那样做。但无论如何，他说，如果有人要写，他希望我来写。部分原因是我没有，我想是因为我没有私心。我不是一个带着关于这个领域的各种想法和概念的心理学家。
And there's not very many people that could write about Hellman in an unbiased way. Yeah, I think so. And because he's really, he's out there, you know, he's a very controversial director. And even in the Jungian world. And so I just dove into it and started going out there and interviewing people. And we, Alice and I went to Ireland, where he'd gone to school at Trinity College in Dublin. And we went there with he and his wife.
而且没有多少人能以公正的方式写希尔曼。是的，我想是这样。因为他真的很特别，你知道，他是一位非常有争议的导演。即使在荣格世界里也是如此。所以我只是投入其中，开始出去采访人们。爱丽丝和我去了爱尔兰，他在那里读过都柏林圣三一学院。我们和他和他的妻子一起去了那里。
And then I went to Zurich and interviewed people at the Jung Institute, where he'd started out and where he met Jung in the 1950s and had known him pretty well. And Jung had then appointed him to be the first director of studies of the Jung Institute, a very prestigious position. Yeah, that was one of the questions that I had. I think your line, if I'm remembering in that book, I read that when my daughter was born. So that was six years ago now. But you said that when Jung died, there was a huge vacuum of a father wound or something that he was a man that kept his opinions close and that did not give out approval very freely, that there was kind of a power vacuum.
然后我去了苏黎世，采访了荣格学院的人，他在那里起步，并在20世纪50年代遇到了荣格，而且对他相当了解。荣格当时任命他为荣格学院的第一任研究主任，这是一个非常显赫的职位。是的，这是我有的问题之一。如果我没记错的话，我在那本书里读到，那是我女儿出生的时候。所以那是六年前的事了。但你说过，当荣格去世时，出现了一个巨大的父亲创伤的真空，或者类似的东西，他是一个把自己的观点藏得很紧，不轻易给予认可的人，有一种权力真空。
And it always, I mean, I kind of read between the lines of a lot of things I knew about the Institute early on that, you know, C.A. Meyer had had kind of a falling out with you uh disagreement and when hellman is appointed to be the provisional director as this upstart i mean i don't think meyer ever really forgave him for that yeah i don't think so either i mean i never knew meyer or interviewed him but because he was dead by the time i was doing the book but uh i got the feeling he wasn't really a nice guy he was very well known uh he was young's uh you know aid to de camp for a while, or at least, you know, a fellow analyst that worked with him. But he got married. Yeah, and he was. And then it got really, I get into this in volume one, it got to be a sticky situation because Hillman was eventually fired as director of studies by the Jung Institute
而且，我的意思是，我从我所知道的关于学院早期的很多事情中读出了弦外之音，你知道，C.A.迈耶（C.A. Meyer）和荣格闹翻了，有分歧，当希尔曼被任命为临时主任时，作为一个暴发户，我的意思是，我不认为迈耶真的原谅了他。是的，我也不这么认为。我的意思是，我从来没见过迈耶或采访过他，因为我写书的时候他已经去世了，但我感觉他并不是一个好人。他非常出名，他是荣格的副官，或者至少，你知道，和他一起工作的同事分析师。但他结婚了。是的，他是。然后情况变得非常棘手，我在第一卷中写到了这一点，因为希尔曼最终被荣格学院解雇了，担任研究主任，
for having had an affair with one of his patients, and at the same time, Meyer, who was pushing for Hillman's dismissal, turned out was having an affair with Hillman's wife, Kate. Then he called the man that Hillman had an affair with the wife of and said, hey, listen, Hillman did this, and if you want to sue him, I'll pay for the lawyer. Yeah. That's pretty wild it's pretty hypocritical too i just i would say but anyway that's and then when helman confronted him about having an affair with his wife he said oh that's between you and your wife or something like that just missed him completely so yeah anyway but it was well it was an interesting thing that happened because it moved Hillman into a whole new realm that he then fathered along with Rafael Lopez Pedraza and Pat Berry, who was a student of his, not the one he had the affair with the first time it got dismissed but um he also had a relationship with pat eventually and they got married and uh and they they worked together uh with uh raphael to create what's called
因为他与他的一名病人有染，与此同时，推动希尔曼被解雇的迈耶，结果却与希尔曼的妻子凯特（Kate）有染。然后他给那个希尔曼与之有染的妻子的丈夫打电话说，嘿，听着，希尔曼做了这件事，如果你想起诉他，我会支付律师费。是的。这太疯狂了，这也很虚伪，我只想说，但无论如何，这就是……然后当希尔曼就他与他妻子有染一事与他对质时，他说，哦，那是你和你妻子之间的事，或者类似的话，完全无视了他。所以，是的，无论如何，但这是一件有趣的事情，因为它把希尔曼带入了一个全新的领域，他随后与拉斐尔·洛佩兹·佩德拉萨（Rafael Lopez Pedraza）和帕特·贝里（Pat Berry）一起培育了这个领域，帕特·贝里是他的学生，不是他第一次被解雇时有染的那个人，但……他最终也与帕特建立了关系，他们结婚了，他们与拉斐尔一起工作，创造了所谓的
archetypal psychology which was very different than the analytical psychology that jung had had created um different in the sense that it was polytheistic. It harkened back to the gods of Greece and then the Renaissance scholars. And Hellman was obsessed with polytheism and really did not like Judaism or Christianity. I mean, I think when I had talked to David Tacey about his analysis with Hellman, he said at one point, Hellman said, quit having dreams about Christianity, start dreaming about Greece. I can believe it. Yeah. Yeah. Well, you know, it was all about bringing and introducing a new element, which were the archetypes, you know, and which were myths and imagination and getting people away from, not that it was wrong, but the personalized psychology, the emphasis on the self and Hillman's psychology, which was analytical, And he was he was hearkening back to an earlier time to connect people.
原型心理学，这与荣格创造的分析心理学非常不同。不同之处在于它是多神论的。它回溯到希腊诸神和文艺复兴时期的学者。希尔曼痴迷于多神论，真的不喜欢犹太教或基督教。我的意思是，我想当我与大卫·塔西（David Tacey）谈论他与希尔曼的分析时，他说有一次，希尔曼说，别再做关于基督教的梦了，开始做关于希腊的梦吧。我能相信。是的。是的。好吧，你知道，这一切都是为了引入一个新的元素，即原型，你知道，也就是神话和想象力，让人们远离——并不是说它是错的——个性化的心理学，对自我的强调，以及希尔曼的心理学，它是分析性的。他回溯到更早的时代来连接人们。
He called it as Keats, the poet, had he called it soul making. And how do you how do you reach the essence of yourself in order to become more of who you are? Well, even though that shocked a lot of people who were like, who just that because i mean i think unionism the early days of the institute it was held back by being tethered to the language of psychoanalysis that it was intellectualizing and thinking and analyzing and not an experience yeah and so i mean he said and i don't know that hillman ever really found out a way to apply archetypal psychology as a technique i mean it was more of a concept you know, that he saw what was wrong with things. But, you know, he was, everyone kind of was reacted with shock when he left the Institute
他称之为——正如诗人济慈（Keats）所说——灵魂制造（soul making）。你如何达到你自己的本质，以便成为更多的你自己？好吧，尽管这震惊了很多人，他们只是……因为我的意思是，我认为荣格主义在学院的早期，它被束缚在精神分析的语言中，它是理智化、思考和分析，而不是体验。是的，所以我的意思是，他说——我不知道希尔曼是否真的找到了一种应用原型心理学作为技术的方法——我的意思是，它更多的是一个概念，你知道，他看到了事情的错误之处。但是，你知道，当他离开学院时，每个人都感到震惊。
and did that. But then it was kind of ahead of his time. And that like most of the best models of psychotherapy we have that were coming, you know, trying to fight back against the cognitive revolution during the 80s and CBT and all that. They were Jungian analysts who left the Institutes because they wanted a somatic and an experiential piece, the direct experience. And I mean, you know, Arnie Mandel left and made process therapy. Sidron Halstone left and made voice dialogue.
并做了那个。但它有点超前于他的时代。就像我们拥有的最好的心理治疗模型一样，它们在80年代试图反击认知革命和CBT等等。他们是离开学院的荣格分析师，因为他们想要一个躯体和体验的部分，直接的体验。我的意思是，你知道，阿尼·曼德尔（Arnie Mandel）离开了，创造了过程疗法。西德隆·哈尔斯通（Sidron Halstone）离开了，创造了声音对话。
I mean, a ton of those guys were all Jungian analysts running the institutes who left to do essentially, I mean, they were on the same quest as Hillman, is how do you directly experience this stuff and how do you place it in the body? running the institutes who left to do essentially, I mean, they were on the same quest as Hillman, is how do you directly experience this stuff and how do you place it in the body? And Hillman was the first analyst that I found ever in the history of the institute to say that the archetypes have a somatic component, that you are not feeling the whole image
我的意思是，那些家伙中有一大堆都是经营学院的荣格分析师，他们离开后基本上做了——我的意思是，他们和希尔曼追求的是同一个目标，即你如何直接体验这些东西，以及你如何将它置于身体中？经营学院的那些人离开后基本上做了——我的意思是，他们和希尔曼追求的是同一个目标，即你如何直接体验这些东西，以及你如何将它置于身体中？希尔曼是我在学院历史上发现的第一个说原型具有躯体成分的分析师，即你没有感受到整个意象，
unless you find it in your body, which is the thing that brought me to him because I was trying to get people to feel an image physically, to feel an emotion physically to heal trauma really early in my career yeah well that's really interesting and and you know it's kind of like there's all these different gods that we incorporate is the way he you know that's the polytheistic way of looking at things and we have we have once he said of himself he said i i uh i i make my way with my hermes opportunism right he loved dionysus uh and he aphrodite he invoked these different gods even with his patients you know as as as ways to connect to those parts of ourselves, I think I would say. So yeah, it was really a fascinating new
除非你在你的身体中找到它，这就是把我带向他的原因，因为我试图让人们在身体上感受一个意象，在身体上感受一种情绪，以在我的职业生涯早期真正治愈创伤。是的，这真的很有趣，而且你知道，这有点像我们融入的所有这些不同的神，这就是他看待事物的方式，你知道，那是看待事物的多神论方式。我们有……他曾这样评价自己，他说，我用我的赫尔墨斯（Hermes）机会主义来开辟道路，对吧？他热爱狄俄尼索斯（Dionysus），他阿佛洛狄忒（Aphrodite），他甚至与他的病人一起援引这些不同的神，你知道，作为连接我们内心那些部分的方式，我想我会这么说。所以是的，这确实是一个迷人的新
approach that gathered all these young people who were searching for something and came to Zurich in search of Jung and led Jung in the early 1970s. Hippies on the road. I did some of that myself. I just hitchhiked all over the place. I'm jealous. It's not the same road that it once was. If you sell your shoes. Unfortunately, I wish it was. I wish that younger people could experience what I did
方法，聚集了所有这些寻找某种东西并来到苏黎世寻找荣格的年轻人，并在20世纪70年代初引导了荣格。路上的嬉皮士。我自己也做过一些。我只是到处搭便车。我很嫉妒。它不再是曾经的那条路了。如果你卖掉你的鞋子。不幸的是，我希望是。我希望年轻人能体验我所经历的
back then. I wasn't one of those who went to Zurich. A lot of these young people enrolled at the Young Institute. Then Hillman did these amazing nights called Spring House. That's what the name of the place was, right? In Zurich. And all these folks gathered and they would study these esoteric texts like the Picatrix. And that was a medieval text. And magic was very involved with that and and the the uh the uh memory theater of don
那时。我不是那些去苏黎世的人之一。很多这些年轻人注册了荣格学院。然后希尔曼做了这些被称为“春天之屋”（Spring House）的奇妙夜晚。那是那个地方的名字，对吧？在苏黎世。所有这些人聚集在一起，他们会研究这些深奥的文本，比如《皮卡特里克斯》（Picatrix）。那是一本中世纪的文本。魔法与此非常相关，还有……唐的记忆剧场
camillo and and bringing these things to the light again that had been definitely forgotten you know and i thought about it was they would all drink wine and and get toasted and you know things would happen like uh one night rafael who was a wild man himself, very close to Hellman for years. And he was from Cuba originally. And one night they were talking about one of these, about Dionysus, I think. And suddenly a drunk fell through the window. Yeah. And Raphael said, you see, we constellated.
卡米洛（Camillo），并再次将这些被遗忘的东西带到光明中，你知道，我想到了，他们都会喝葡萄酒，喝得醉醺醺的，你知道，事情会发生，比如有一天晚上，拉斐尔（Rafael）本人就是一个狂人，多年来与希尔曼非常亲近。他最初来自古巴。有一天晚上，他们正在谈论其中一个，关于狄俄尼索斯，我想。突然一个醉汉从窗户掉了进来。是的。拉斐尔说，你看，我们星座化了。
And they created it right in front of him. Yeah. Hellman was really, his like little posse was very instant constellating gods. That was like the language that they would always use when something manifested. But I mean, they got into those things because they saw them as kind of projections of the deep unconscious. That by looking at these medieval texts, you could see something where somebody who was not aware of the psychology we have now is kind of telling on themselves by projecting these things into pre-scientific sciences like alchemy or into summoning magic, into summoning angels like John Dee, or mythology,
他们在他的面前创造了它。是的。希尔曼真的，他的小圈子非常擅长星座化神。那是当某事显现时他们总是会使用的语言。但我的意思是，他们进入这些事情是因为他们将它们视为深层潜意识的投射。通过观察这些中世纪文本，你可以看到一些东西，即一个不了解我们现在拥有的心理学的人，通过将这些东西投射到前科学科学（如炼金术）或召唤魔法中，比如召唤像约翰·迪（John Dee）那样的天使，或神话，
the gods, that when people don't create religion in a vacuum, we have something inside of us and we've projected it out in our early days and that we can go back and look at that to kind of understand who we are. Yeah. And I think that's not always understood. I mean, I think that sometimes people just think that, you know, Jungian therapy equals, you know, Americans a lot of times it like, it just equals therapy plus Jesus or therapy plus they believe in magic and the tarot. And it's like, they see things as pieces of self, you know, and that's something that people who aren't coming from that background don't always get. Yeah, it's so true. And a lot of, a lot of these young people who came then in the early seventies,
诸神，当人们不在真空中创造宗教时，我们内心深处有某种东西，我们在早期把它投射出来，我们可以回去看看它，以某种方式理解我们是谁。是的。而且我认为这并不总是被理解。我的意思是，我认为有时人们只是认为，你知道，荣格疗法等于，你知道，美国人很多时候认为，它只是等于疗法加耶稣，或者疗法加他们相信魔法和塔罗牌。而且，他们将事物视为自我的碎片，你知道，那些没有这种背景的人并不总是明白这一点。是的，太对了。而且很多，很多这些在70年代初来的年轻人，
well, there was Tom Hapakabasenskas and Robert Hinshaw and Paul Kugler. Lots of these guys then became analysts themselves and brought a lot of these ideas with them, of course, after they left Zurich. Ed Casey, who was... There were a number of these folks that I interviewed and write about in
好吧，有汤姆·哈帕卡巴森卡斯（Tom Hapakabasenskas）、罗伯特·欣肖（Robert Hinshaw）和保罗·库格勒（Paul Kugler）。当然，这些家伙中有很多后来自己成为了分析师，并在离开苏黎世后带走了很多这些想法。埃德·凯西（Ed Casey），他是……我采访并写到的这些人中有很多。
the biography. Yeah, it was a whole new road, and it was an exciting era you know i mean coming out of the 60s and and uh when the cynics and puer as hillman described in the lecture and then you know book of the same name you know the cynics was the the forces the sort of like the old guard you know among the young but didn't like Hillman very much a lot. They thought he was breaking away from the young versus the Puer, which Hillman described himself as.
传记。是的，那是一条全新的路，那是一个令人兴奋的时代，你知道，我的意思是，走出60年代，以及……当愤世嫉俗者（Cynics）和纯真少年（Puer）正如希尔曼在讲座和同名书中描述的那样，你知道，愤世嫉俗者是那些力量，有点像荣格派中的老卫兵，你知道，他们不太喜欢希尔曼。他们认为他正在脱离荣格，而纯真少年，希尔曼形容自己就是那样。
You know, always bringing new ideas into the light. But you had to have both. I mean, you had to combine the discipline of the cynics with the inspired vision of the Puer in order to really get somewhere in life. And that was one of the things that he talked about a lot well i think he struggled to reconcile him and you see it in his
你知道，总是把新的想法带到光明中。但你必须两者兼备。我的意思是，你必须将愤世嫉俗者的纪律与纯真少年的灵感愿景结合起来，才能在生活中真正有所成就。这是他经常谈论的事情之一。好吧，我认为他努力调和他们，你在他的
books where they're kind of very romantic and idealistic or they're just incredibly intellectual written for intellectuals and then he doesn't know why they're not as successful as thomas moore's books yeah and and i think you know the thing that is interesting to me because i relate a lot to hillman's like worse angels you know like i want to check some of my own impulses. And but, you know, he he is kind of crazy, you know, towards the end of his life. You know, there's all there's a lot of things where he doesn't quite integrate it. And I think, you know, he really was looking for this way of directly experiencing archetypes. He wanted looking his whole career was trying to find a direct access to soul and everything he wrote, you see that hunger. And I wonder,
书中看到它们，它们非常浪漫和理想主义，或者它们只是极其理智，为知识分子而写，然后他不知道为什么它们不像托马斯·摩尔的书那样成功。是的，而且我认为，你知道，让我感兴趣的是，因为我与希尔曼的“坏天使”有很多共鸣，你知道，比如我想检查我自己的某些冲动。但是，你知道，他——他在生命尽头有点疯狂，你知道，有很多事情他并没有完全整合。而且我认为，你知道，他确实在寻找这种直接体验原型的途径。他想——他整个职业生涯都在试图找到通往灵魂的直接途径，在他写的一切中，你都能看到那种饥渴。我想知道，
because I haven't, I'm excited for your book because I haven't really seen a lot of, you know, secondhand accounts of it. But I wonder if when the red book came out, if he saw that and he, if that was what that, if that fulfilled, scratched that itch for him, you know, that, that process of active imagination was pretty similar to archetypal psychology. He didn't know Jung read the Red Book until it was published. It does look a lot like the process that he was trying to make and doesn't ever really do case studies of and doesn't ever really describe techniques for. Yeah, I mean, he was knocked out by that book.
因为我还没有——我很期待你的书，因为我还没有真正看到很多，你知道，关于它的二手记录。但我很好奇，当《红书》（Red Book）出版时，他看到了它，如果那是——如果那满足了，抓住了他的那个痒处，你知道，那个主动想象的过程与原型心理学非常相似。他不知道荣格读过《红书》，直到它出版。它看起来确实很像他试图制造的过程，而且他从来没有真正做过案例研究，也从来没有真正描述过技术。是的，我的意思是，他被那本书惊呆了。
And he realized this is toward the end of his life. And he gave talks on the Red Book at several venues, one of them with Sonu Shandasani and the actress Helen Hunt. Well, then for the dead, after the Red Book, him discussing it, that's probably one of the best things he ever wrote.
他意识到这是在他生命尽头的时候。他在几个场合就《红书》发表了演讲，其中一个场合有索努·沙达萨尼（Sonu Shandasani）和女演员海伦·亨特（Helen Hunt）。好吧，那么对于死者，在《红书》之后，他讨论它，那可能是他写过的最好的东西之一。
It's incredible. And where you get into the dead, the ancestors, which has always been very important to him. He had the pictures on his wall. But yeah, he said to me that he realized that he and Jung were really on the same page in a lot of ways that he had not realized until he saw that book. And he had a dream at that time. I think I write about this in Volume 3. He didn't talk to me about dreams too much.
这太不可思议了。而且你进入死者，祖先，这对他来说一直非常重要。他墙上有照片。但是的，他告诉我，他意识到他和荣格在很多方面确实在同一页上，直到他看到那本书，他才意识到这一点。他在那个时候做了一个梦。我想我在第三卷中写到了这一点。他没有跟我谈太多关于梦的事情。
But he had a dream. He had a number of dreams about Jung through the years. And in one of them, Jung was saying to him about their work. It's beyond human history. Yeah. Which I thought was pretty wonderful. I wonder. See, that's my question. Because when I see Hellman's career, I just see the father wound running rampant.
但他做了一个梦。多年来他做过很多关于荣格的梦。在其中一个梦里，荣格在对他说关于他们的工作。它超越了人类历史。是的。我觉得这很美妙。我想知道。看，那是我的问题。因为当我看到希尔曼的职业生涯时，我只看到了父亲创伤的猖獗。
And I don't even think he would have gone back just to the Greeks. I mean, I think if you let him go, he would have gone back to the mother cult and be going into the cave with the Venus of Willendorf. I mean, he really was trying to go all the way to the bottom of something. And I wonder, you know, he wrote Lament for the Dead, and I see that there. But I'm interested in the biography of when he sees the Red Book. He kind of forgives some of the animosity he had with Jung and finds peace. He does. Absolutely, he does. And you'll read about that in Volume 3, because it was a really important realization that he came to not too long before he died.
我甚至不认为他会只回到希腊人那里。我的意思是，我认为如果你让他走，他会回到母系崇拜，并带着维伦多夫的维纳斯（Venus of Willendorf）进入洞穴。我的意思是，他确实试图一直走到某件事的底部。而且我想知道，你知道，他写了《为死者哀悼》（Lament for the Dead），我看到了那里。但我对当他看到《红书》时的传记很感兴趣。他某种程度上原谅了他与荣格之间的一些敌意，并找到了平静。他确实。绝对，他做到了。你会在第三卷中读到这一点，因为这是一个非常重要的认识，他在去世前不久才达到。
He was 85 years old when he died in 2011. And by that point, I had written, well, I never started out to write a three-volume book, right? I was going to do one volume. And I was blessed to have many, many interviews with him in the course of that, all of which, you know, I'd be writing. And I shared with him what I was writing about these aspects of his life. So I never got beyond a certain point in his life,
他2011年去世时85岁。到那时，我已经写了——好吧，我从来没打算写一本三卷本的书，对吧？我打算写一卷。我有幸在过程中对他进行了许多许多次采访，所有这些，你知道，我都会写下来。我与他分享了我所写的关于他生活中的这些方面的内容。所以我从来没有超过他生命中的某个点，
in turn, before he died, but I was able to sit with him and have him elaborate on these various themes as he read the chapters that I had put together about various periods in his life. And that was, wow, that was amazing. And also to see him give these talks on the Red Book during that period and read the Red Book myself. I mean, I was blown away by it too and by the artistry of Jung's beautiful paintings in the book as well, which I had no idea he was that talented an artist. One of the things that Hellman does, he does that is very original kind of technique is saying that if anima and animus are archetypes, then they're present in both genders.
反过来，在他去世之前，但我能够和他坐在一起，让他详细阐述这些不同的主题，当他阅读我整理的关于他生活中不同时期的章节时。那真是，哇，那太神奇了。而且还能看到他在那个时期就《红书》发表这些演讲，并亲自阅读《红书》。我的意思是，我也被它惊呆了，也被书中荣格美丽的画作的艺术性所震撼，我根本不知道他是一位如此有天赋的艺术家。希尔曼所做的事情之一，他所做的是非常原创的技术，即说如果阿尼玛（anima）和阿尼姆斯（animus）是原型，那么它们存在于两种性别中。
Men have an animus too. Do you see any of that in the end of his life? Does that play a part in anything that is to come in your story? Yeah, well, I think the anima is always, I mean, he was always in pursuit of the anima, right? But it's interesting that, and we're skipping ahead a bit here, but it is in volume two where I write about his connection to the mythopoetic men's movement.
男人也有阿尼姆斯。你在他生命尽头看到了吗？这在你的故事中即将到来的任何事情中起作用吗？是的，好吧，我认为阿尼玛总是——我的意思是，他总是追求阿尼玛，对吧？但有趣的是，我们在这里跳过了一点，但我在第二卷中写到了他与神话诗意男性运动（mythopoetic men's movement）的联系。
Yeah. And that was a huge thing for him. We can skip ahead to there, perhaps, and then come back to other things. But, you know, it was a period in his life. He turned 60. He and Pat Berry, who had been married for 20 years, were getting close to splitting up. Aranos, which was this amazing place in Switzerland on Lake Lago Maggiore where he'd been going and meeting these underground giants for
是的。这对他是件大事。我们也许可以跳到那里，然后再回到其他事情上。但是，你知道，那是他生命中的一个时期。他60岁了。他和帕特·贝里（Pat Berry），结婚20年了，正接近分手。阿拉诺斯（Aranos），那是瑞士马焦雷湖（Lake Lago Maggiore）上一个神奇的地方，他一直在那里，并会见这些地下巨人，大约
also pretty much 20 years. He starts donning a Casablanca trench coat and fedora during this period of his life too. Yes. And so that's coming to an end for him as well. And that's when he's met Robert Bly, the poet, and he meets this storyteller who uses fairy tales of all things with men named Michael Mead. Yeah, I'm familiar. I think we were going to interview him in September fairy tales of all things with men named Michael Meade. And they formed... Yeah, I'm familiar. Yeah.
也差不多20年了。他开始在这个生命阶段穿上卡萨布兰卡（Casablanca）风衣和软呢帽。是的。所以这对他也即将结束。那时他遇到了诗人罗伯特·布莱（Robert Bly），他遇到了这位讲故事的人，他用童话故事，竟然是童话故事，与名为迈克尔·米德（Michael Mead）的男人在一起。是的，我很熟悉。我想我们九月要采访他……竟然是童话故事，与名为迈克尔·米德的男人在一起。他们组成了……是的，我很熟悉。是的。
I think we were going to interview him in September, and our schedules keep not aligning. Oh, well, that'd be great if you could. And you could, of course, ask him about his relationship with James Hillman because they had a very powerful and not always... Well, it was frayed toward the end, I guess, but they had a lot of amazing... God, I mean, the things that they did with groups of men.
我想我们九月要采访他，但我们的时间表一直对不上。哦，好吧，如果你能采访他那就太好了。而且你当然可以问他关于他和詹姆斯·希尔曼的关系，因为他们有一种非常强大，而且并不总是……好吧，我想最后有点紧张，但他们有很多惊人的……天哪，我的意思是，他们与男人群体所做的事情。
I talk about it now because the anima part, but it was like men have feelings that aren't just feminine feelings. You know, they have feelings that are often, you know, squelched in themselves, not allowed to come to the surface. And they went through just these incredible conversations where they would use, Mead would use a fairy tale. Well, I would read the poetry of Yeats or Rumi or whoever, right? And Hillman would give these intellectual talks. On an Akhmatov, too, he would always, I'm blanking on the poem, but yeah, I've got a lot of those tapes.
我现在谈论它是因为阿尼玛部分，但就像男人有不仅仅是女性化的感觉。你知道，他们有经常，你知道，在自己内心被压抑，不允许浮出水面的感觉。他们进行了这些令人难以置信的对话，他们会使用，米德会使用一个童话故事。好吧，我会读叶芝（Yeats）或鲁米（Rumi）或任何人的诗歌，对吧？而希尔曼会发表这些理智的演讲。关于阿赫玛托娃（Akhmatov），他也总是，我想不起那首诗了，但是的，我有很多那些录音。
It's the recordings of Me me drumming and telling a myth and Helvin chiming in. Yeah. Yeah. Well, they had a great relationship of the three of them as teachers and they would bounce things off each other and they would be a hundred men in a room there for a week in the Redwoods, right? And in Minnesota or Maine california mendocino and you know it was interpreted by the media a lot of this especially as it became more of a
那是米德打鼓和讲神话，希尔曼插话的录音。是的。是的。好吧，他们三个人作为老师有着很好的关系，他们会互相交流想法，他们会在红杉林里，对吧？在明尼苏达州或缅因州，加利福尼亚州门多西诺（Mendocino），你知道，它被媒体解读了很多，特别是当它变得更像一个
movement quote unquote and there's a lot of publicity about it in the 1990s and it was often dismissed you know as oh it's just these guys out in the woods you know getting off uh dancing with each other and talking bad about their wives and well i think it was viewed too as kind of a misogynist thing you know that women weren't allowed or something and but a lot of it i think they saw the kind of toxic rambo culture of the 80s and they were trying to save men from themselves and try and protect women from men by healing trauma you know so many of those stories are about how do you not take your PTSD? And the myths that Mead is drumming and telling, they're like, how do you not take your PTSD
运动，引用引号，在90年代有很多关于它的宣传，它经常被驳回，你知道，哦，这只是这些家伙在树林里，你知道，跳舞，说他们妻子的坏话，而且，好吧，我认为它也被视为一种厌女症的东西，你知道，女性不允许参加什么的，但我认为他们中的很多人看到了80年代那种有毒的兰博（Rambo）文化，他们试图从自己手中拯救男人，并试图通过治愈创伤来保护女性免受男人的伤害，你知道，这么多故事都是关于你如何不带走你的创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）？而米德打鼓和讲述的神话，它们就像，你如何不带走你的PTSD
out on other people? How do you own it and hold it and heal it? Yeah, yeah, exactly. A lot of these guys who came to these events were Vietnam vets. They've been through terrible PTSD experiences. A lot of them, you know, abandoned fathers. That was a big subject. But the effort was to get men beyond those things and explore the soul, really, the depths of themselves with each other in a safe space where, you know, they didn't allow reporters, usually.
发泄在别人身上？你如何拥有它、保持它并治愈它？是的，是的，正是如此。很多参加这些活动的家伙都是越战老兵。他们经历过可怕的PTSD经历。他们很多人，你知道，被父亲抛弃。那是一个大话题。但努力是让男人超越这些事情，探索灵魂，真正地，在安全的空间里与彼此探索他们内心深处，你知道，他们通常不允许记者进入。
And many times, I mean, there's many stories about when they would go home, the wives would say, wow, what happened to you? You know, you're a whole other guy in all kinds of ways. So it was vitally important to, and I interviewed lots of people about this. I mean, there should be a whole book on it in itself. I'm not going to do it, but somebody should. And for Hillman, it was a very important thing because he became really just one of the guys, you know. Yeah. And he was this egghead, you know, that had to kind of do sometimes outrageous things in order to connect to these folks who didn't really trust this erudite guy talking about all these things, which he did.
很多时候，我是说，有很多故事讲到他们回家时，妻子们会说，哇，你怎么变了？你知道，你在各方面都完全变成了另一个人。所以这至关重要，我为此采访了很多人。我的意思是，这本身就应该写成一整本书。我不会去写，但应该有人来写。对于希尔曼来说，这是一件非常重要的事情，因为他真的成为了他们中的一员，你知道。是的。他是个书呆子，你知道，他有时不得不做一些离谱的事情，才能与这些人建立联系，因为他们并不信任这个谈论所有这些深奥事物的博学之人，而他确实做到了。
There's stories I tell in the book about one time Hillman, it's one of the early events, he fashioned some headgear out of ferns and he walked into a group of these men and he said, my name is Fern because he thought you made up names of these things. Another time, just to get his goat, right, some of the men had one of their people walk in without any clothes on and take a seat. And what Hillman did was he just looked at the room and looked at the guy
我在书中讲过一些故事，有一次希尔曼在早期的活动中，他用蕨类植物做了一些头饰，走进一群男人中间说，我叫蕨类，因为他认为你们编造了这些东西的名字。还有一次，为了激怒他，对吧，有些人让他们的一个同伴一丝不挂地走进来坐下。希尔曼所做的只是环顾房间，看着那个人
and he said, would you stand up, please? Introduce yourself. And it endeared him, right? Of course, because he could do these kinds of things and would, because they were sincere. You know, he wasn't making stuff up, although he was a very good actor. I mean, and he loved Shakespeare. I mean, Boardwalk boardwalk city man like yeah
然后他说，请你站起来好吗？自我介绍一下。这让他赢得了他们的喜爱，对吧？当然，因为他能做这些事情，而且愿意做，因为他是真诚的。你知道，他不是在编造，尽管他是个非常好的演员。我的意思是，他热爱莎士比亚。我的意思是，木板路帝国的人，是的
exactly yeah yeah um well i don't i want to be respectful of your time and also get to you know your second book that you wanted to talk about but i mean just as an in-betweener um because a lot of times you know we want to talk talk about the writer's process or the artist's process on these things. And I mean, you're an investigative journalist, but you've written about the environment. You've written about, you know, not conspiracy theories like in a typical way, but kind of the power behind the power. Or maybe what in our own, you know, American mythology mythology maybe we're blind to. Because it is a myth. Nationalism is kind of a myth, just like advertising and pop culture and all these things.
完全正确，是的，嗯，我不想占用你太多时间，也想谈谈你想聊的第二本书，但我的意思是，作为一个过渡，因为很多时候，你知道，我们想谈谈这些事情中作家的创作过程或艺术家的创作过程。我的意思是，你是一位调查记者，但你写过关于环境的文章。你写过，你知道，不是那种典型的阴谋论，而是某种权力背后的权力。或者也许是我们自己的，你知道，美国神话中我们可能视而不见的东西。因为它确实是一个神话。民族主义是一种神话，就像广告、流行文化和所有这些东西一样。
And also shamanism, personal work. It seems like all of those things sort of are in the category of mythology. Would you agree? Or is that what you're doing? I don't want to speak for you, but that's an open-ended question. I mean, yeah, in a way, I guess I am. I'm somebody whose career as a writer, I guess, most everything I've done is about bringing something into the light
还有萨满教、个人修行。似乎所有这些东西都属于神话的范畴。你同意吗？还是说这就是你在做的事情？我不想替你代言，但这是一个开放式的问题。我的意思是，是的，在某种程度上，我想我是。我是一个作家，我想，我所做的大部分事情都是为了把一些东西带到光明之中
that's been in the dark. And I hadn't thought about it until recently, really, in this way. But, you know, I explored the mysteries of the Kennedy assassination and brought that to light in a pathbreaking book. I wrote a book called Black Genius and the American Experience, which was about these incredible African-Americans that my son was biracial. And I kind of wrote the book, is biracial and still around, wrote the book sort of with him in mind of what he should know about some of these figures, you know, in all different fields. Then I wrote a book about this mysterious interaction between whales and humans, where in Mexico...
那些曾经处于黑暗中的东西。直到最近，我才真正以这种方式思考过它。但是，你知道，我探索了肯尼迪遇刺的谜团，并在一部开创性的书中将其公之于众。我写了一本名为《黑人天才与美国经验》的书，是关于这些了不起的非裔美国人的，我的儿子是混血儿。我写这本书时，某种程度上是考虑到他，他应该了解这些在不同领域的人物，你知道。然后我写了一本关于鲸鱼和人类之间神秘互动的书，在墨西哥……
You may have just made a movie about that one, right? James Cameron. Exactly. But yeah, I mean, there's these great whales in this lagoon in Baja, Mexico, halfway down the peninsula, that mysteriously began coming up to small boats about 30, 40 years ago. And I had this experience. I went down there to write about this salt works that Mitsubishi was planning to build with the Mexican government to wipe out this habitat, basically, where the mother whales brought their young every year after a 5,000-mile migration. And these whales would come up to you and introduce their young. And you're petting whales in the wild. And they like to have their gums rubbed. So I wrote a book about this and followed their migration all the way to Russia. So anyway, various things like that, that I have
你可能刚拍了一部关于那个的电影，对吧？詹姆斯·卡梅隆。没错。但是，是的，我的意思是，在墨西哥下加利福尼亚半岛中部的那个泻湖里，有这些伟大的鲸鱼，大约30、40年前，它们神秘地开始靠近小船。我有过这样的经历。我到那里去写关于三菱公司计划与墨西哥政府合作建造盐场的事情，这基本上会摧毁这个栖息地，而母鲸每年在迁徙5000英里后都会带着幼鲸来到这里。这些鲸鱼会游到你身边，介绍它们的幼崽。你可以在野外抚摸鲸鱼。它们喜欢被揉搓牙龈。所以我写了一本关于这个的书，并一路追踪它们的迁徙路线到了俄罗斯。总之，诸如此类的事情，我
explored and been blessed to have an opportunity to look into. And that includes this book that I wrote a few years ago. Again, it's without James Hillman, I never would have written it in a sense, I can't tell you why, but it's called My Mysterious Son, a life-changing passage between schizophrenia and shamanism. Do you mind if we introduce schizophrenia for people who may not be aware of the condition or the different parts of it? Yeah, well, it's a very traumatic, sudden onset illness that happens to thousands of young people around the age of 17, usually 18. Our drum roll period is a little bit
探索过，并且有幸有机会去研究。这包括我几年前写的那本书。同样，如果没有詹姆斯·希尔曼，我可能永远不会写它，从某种意义上说，我无法告诉你原因，但它叫《我神秘的儿子：精神分裂症与萨满教之间改变人生的旅程》。你介意我们为那些可能不了解这种疾病或其不同部分的人介绍一下精神分裂症吗？是的，嗯，这是一种非常痛苦的、突发性的疾病，发生在成千上万的年轻人身上，通常在17岁左右，通常是18岁。我们的前驱期稍微
earlier, usually in men than women, but it usually is, you know, kind of late teens for guys and maybe early 20s for women. You know, a couple of things can speed it up or slow down the presentation of it. But a big one that makes the symptoms be fueled a lot is trauma. You know, a couple of things can speed it up or slow down the presentation of it. But a big one that makes the symptoms be fueled a lot is trauma. You know, the genes, you can have 80% of the, and this is kind of me opining, this is maybe a controversial take, but, you know, our genes like inform how we express the trauma, but the trauma is the fuel under the genes. And dopamine disorders like schizophrenia, OCD, manic depressive, and bipolar, like they tend to run in families.
早一点，男性通常比女性早，但通常是，你知道，男性的青少年晚期，女性可能是20岁出头。你知道，有几件事可以加速或减缓它的表现。但一个很大的因素是创伤，它会加剧症状。你知道，有几件事可以加速或减缓它的表现。但一个很大的因素是创伤，它会加剧症状。你知道，基因，你可以拥有80%的，这是我的观点，这可能是一个有争议的看法，但是，你知道，我们的基因决定了我们如何表达创伤，但创伤是基因下的燃料。像精神分裂症、强迫症、躁郁症和双相情感障碍这样的多巴胺紊乱，它们往往有家族遗传倾向。
You know, you'll see that. But it is the trauma that sets it off. And a lot of times by treating the trauma, you can bring the symptom down and reduce the need for the medications, which have some pretty severe side effects some of the time, quite a bit. And I think, when was Franklin diagnosed? When was he first going on medication? 17. Or no, what like year, calendar year? Well, 1990s, 1996. Okay. Yeah. So, and there have been like some pretty good advancements since then. One of the things
你知道，你会看到这一点。但正是创伤引发了它。很多时候，通过治疗创伤，你可以减轻症状并减少对药物的需求，这些药物有时会有相当严重的副作用。我想，富兰克林是什么时候被诊断出来的？他第一次开始服药是什么时候？17岁。或者不，是什么年份，日历年？嗯，1990年代，1996年。好的。是的。所以，从那时起已经有了一些相当不错的进展。其中一件事
that we can do now, which not everyone knows about it, I'm mentioning it in case anyone with schizophrenia or someone who knows someone with schizophrenia is listening is, you know, a lot of the antipsychotics have a side effect where they may have a metabolic syndrome where people gain a ton of weight. They don't know when they're full and it changes your personality to gain 200 pounds. It changes a lot of things. Well, now we know that you can prescribe a low dose of an anticonvulsant like topamats and it counteracts lot of things. Um, well now we know that you can prescribe us a low dose of an anticonvulsant like topamats and it counteracts that metabolic syndrome. So if the antipsychotics working for you, you know, you can go to the psychiatrist, not all the psychiatrists know that.
我们现在可以做的事情，并不是每个人都知道，我提出来是为了以防任何患有精神分裂症或认识精神分裂症患者的人在听，就是，你知道，许多抗精神病药物有一个副作用，可能会导致代谢综合征，人们会体重暴增。他们不知道什么时候吃饱了，体重增加200磅会改变你的性格。它改变了很多事情。嗯，现在我们知道你可以开低剂量的抗惊厥药，比如托吡酯，它可以抵消很多事情。嗯，现在我们知道你可以开低剂量的抗惊厥药，比如托吡酯，它可以抵消那种代谢综合征。所以如果抗精神病药物对你有效，你知道，你可以去看精神科医生，并不是所有的精神科医生都知道这一点。
And there's not a ton of research done about schizophrenia because the people who have it generally are not very wealthy. Um, and there's not very many of them. So it's a tiny, it's a rare disorder anyway. And that's what a part of why it's so cool is that, you know, we will research how to make the 30th statin, even though they all work the same, because every old white guy watching the news is going to get high cholesterol. And we can pretend that this one so we dump all this money into it. Whereas things that are really needed, like antibiotics and antipsychotics, we don't have enough. We don't have good ones. And we're not spending any money researching them. They do in some countries with more of a socialized research mentality. So that's sad. I mean, I think that's wrong because that's what we need. We don't need
而且关于精神分裂症的研究并不多，因为患有这种病的人通常不是很富有。嗯，而且他们的人数也不多。所以无论如何，这是一种微小的、罕见的疾病。这就是为什么它如此令人沮丧的部分原因，你知道，我们会研究如何制造第30种他汀类药物，尽管它们的作用都一样，因为每个看新闻的老白人都可能胆固醇高。我们可以假装这种药有用，所以我们投入了所有的钱。然而，真正需要的东西，比如抗生素和抗精神病药物，我们却不够。我们没有好的药物。而且我们没有花任何钱去研究它们。在一些具有更多社会化研究心态的国家，他们会这样做。所以这很可悲。我的意思是，我认为这是错误的，因为这正是我们所需要的。我们不需要
Quazilla statin. you know. And then also one of the things that is really helpful with the med management now, it's more gentle on the body and it also is just so much easier to help regulate somebody with a thought disorder is there's an injectable medication. So you can get a time release one month to three month, you know, dose of the medication. So if you miss a dose or you're having a lot of stress and the symptoms flare up, you know, you can, you can really stay a lot more stable, you know? So there have been some progress since the nineties, but it still is, it's a hard thing to manage and something we don't spend enough time trying to treat. Yeah. And, and, you know, of course it's marked at the beginning, certainly by, by paranoia and so-called delusional thinking.
夸齐拉他汀。你知道。还有，现在药物管理中非常有帮助的一件事，它对身体更温和，而且帮助调节思维障碍患者也容易得多，那就是有一种注射药物。所以你可以获得长效的一到三个月的药物剂量。所以如果你漏服了一次，或者你承受了很大的压力，症状发作了，你知道，你可以，你真的可以保持稳定得多，你知道？所以自九十年代以来确实取得了一些进展，但它仍然是一个难以管理的事情，而且我们没有花足够的时间去尝试治疗它。是的。而且，你知道，当然，它在开始时肯定是以偏执和所谓的妄想思维为标志的。
And that lasted for a long time with my son. And it was a very tough period, which I describe in the book. But eventually it led me to seek some kind of, not necessarily going off mitigation entirely, but an adjunct to the anesthetic regimen because, God, the side effects were just so severe. And he had put on, just like you described, Franklin had put on 100 pounds. And it was this handsome kid who just suddenly, you know, ballooned up. And it was really, really tough for a long time, but ended up actually through, there
这在我儿子身上持续了很长时间。那是一段非常艰难的时期，我在书中描述过。但最终它引导我寻求某种，不一定是完全停止药物治疗，而是作为药物方案的辅助手段，因为，天哪，副作用实在太严重了。他就像你描述的那样，富兰克林体重增加了100磅。他曾经是个英俊的孩子，突然间，你知道，就肿胀起来了。那是一段非常、非常艰难的长期过程，但最终实际上通过，那里
was a man named Maladoma Sommé, who was a shaman from West Africa at Burkina Faso. And he was part of this men's movement that James Hillman founded. And they got to know each other. And when I was looking for an alternative, something, my wife remembered, I interviewed Melodoma, but just on the phone, I'd never met him. He had been at this landmark gathering of, at Buffalo Gap, West Virginia, 50 black men and 50 white men coming together in a room for a week to really get down and talk about their lives and their soul experiences. But anyway, so I contacted Melodoma and went to him for a divination where he spoke about my ancestors and how the ancestors on my side really didn't understand my son. They didn't know who he was.
有一个叫马洛多马·索梅的人，他是来自西非布基纳法索的萨满。他是詹姆斯·希尔曼创立的男性运动的一部分。他们互相认识。当我寻找替代方案时，我妻子记得，我采访过马洛多马，但只是通过电话，我从未见过他。他曾参加过在西弗吉尼亚州布法罗峡谷举行的那次具有里程碑意义的聚会，50名黑人男性和50名白人男性聚在一起，花了一周时间真正深入探讨他们的生活和灵魂体验。总之，我联系了马洛多马，并去找他进行了一次占卜，他谈到了我的祖先，以及我这边的祖先真的不了解我儿子。他们不知道他是谁。
Of course, they were white. And then the ancestors on Franklin's mother's side were African-American. So I went through a series of rituals. It's a very long story, and I'm not going to be able to tell it all here, but it made a huge difference, especially when we ended up going as a family several years after I first met Maladoma to West Africa, to his village, and spent a month there with a healer that he had. And he prescribed this. We had these big herbal pots that each of us, Franklin's mother and myself, and Franklin would bathe with every day, drink water from. And it was full of these herbs that had been specifically prescribed for us. And we also went
当然，他们是白人。然后富兰克林母亲那边的祖先是非裔美国人。所以我经历了一系列仪式。这是一个很长的故事，我在这里无法全部讲完，但它产生了巨大的影响，特别是在我第一次见到马洛多马几年后，我们全家最终去了西非，去了他的村庄，并和他的治疗师在那里待了一个月。他开了这个处方。我们有这些大草药罐，我们每个人，富兰克林的母亲和我，还有富兰克林，每天都要用它洗澡，喝里面的水。它装满了专门为我们开的草药。我们还经历了一系列
through a series of rituals over there, doing this as a family with a bunch of other people who had come along too, that had their own issues that they were seeking help for. And I tell you, it changed a lot of things. I mean, Franklin went way down on his medication after that. And it's still some years later now, not as much as he was. And he's really so much better than he's been since he had his breakdown at the age of 17. He's living with his mom and doing a lot of great art. We talk all the time. We're way past the very traumatic things that we continued to go through as he was growing up. And he's in his 40s now, and I couldn't be happier about how he's doing. And a lot of that I attribute to, first of all, James Hillman,
在那里的仪式，作为家庭和一群也一起来的人一起做，他们也有自己寻求帮助的问题。我告诉你，它改变了很多事情。我的意思是，在那之后，富兰克林的药量大幅下降。几年后的现在，他服用的药量已经没有那么多了。他真的比他17岁崩溃以来好多了。他和妈妈住在一起，创作了很多很棒的艺术作品。我们经常交谈。我们已经走出了他成长过程中经历的那些非常痛苦的事情。他现在40多岁了，我对他现在的状态感到非常高兴。这很大程度上归功于，首先是詹姆斯·希尔曼，
and then to what Maladoma did for us. He passed away, unfortunately, a couple of years ago. Well, I think one of the things that's kind of cruel, especially if you're seeing somebody who's very rigidly cognitive therapist or people who are more intellectual not intellectual uh but people who are very into the ego is all that we are is they don't understand the disease and they start to treat it like it's a disease and pathologize it and they debate you that this isn't real this isn't real and i mean these are experiences that yeah we didn't pick the time. Yeah, they're kind of inconvenient. Yeah, it's psychosis, but
然后是马洛多马为我们所做的一切。不幸的是，他几年前去世了。嗯，我认为其中一件很残酷的事情，特别是如果你看到一个非常僵化的认知治疗师，或者那些更知识分子——不是知识分子，而是那些非常沉迷于自我的人——他们不了解这种疾病，他们开始把它当作一种疾病来治疗并将其病理化，他们和你争论说这不是真的，这不是真的，我的意思是，这些都是经历，是的，我们没有选择时间。是的，它们有点不方便。是的，这是精神病，但是
they're an opportunity to see our emotional self and our wounds and things that we need to heal. And so a ton of times, you know, somebody who's been on antipsychotics for a long time and needs to stay on antipsychotics to treat the, you know, just have a normal pace of life with schizophrenia when they come to therapy. You know, the psychotic episode's bad. I'm afraid of it and all this stuff. I did all these things I'm embarrassed about. Why did I do that? But then when you say, okay, no, but these, this is symbols, let's treat this more like a dream. You know, what is that telling you? And then all of a sudden it becomes part of me that it's like, oh yeah, you know,
它们是一个观察我们情感自我、伤口以及我们需要治愈的东西的机会。所以很多时候，你知道，一个长期服用抗精神病药物并且需要继续服用以治疗精神分裂症，从而保持正常生活节奏的人，当他们来接受治疗时。你知道，精神病发作很糟糕。我对此感到害怕，所有这些事情。我做了所有这些让我尴尬的事情。我为什么要那样做？但当你告诉他们，好的，不，这些是象征，让我们把这当作梦来对待。你知道，这在告诉你什么？然后突然之间，它成为了我的一部分，就像，哦，是的，你知道，
I do need to indulge this part of myself and I do need to be afraid of this thing, or I, this is what I'm longing to create, you know, there. And then it becomes less of a scary thing. Um, but unfortunately so few, uh, medical professionals do that. And, and it is because they don't do it and they debate you and say oh this is irrational or this is a you know there's not a dragon in your basement whatever instead of just sitting with the image and the emotion even if you can't sit with the image or you don't know what it means you must feel so scared that this stuff's going on you know let's sit with we'll sit with that then when when you lean into that kind of cognitive therapy with with a psychosis what
我确实需要放纵自己的这一部分，我确实需要害怕这个东西，或者我，这就是我渴望创造的东西，你知道，在那里。然后它就变得不那么可怕了。嗯，但不幸的是，很少有医疗专业人员这样做。而且，这是因为他们不这样做，他们和你争论说哦这是非理性的，或者这是一个，你知道，你的地下室里没有龙，等等，而不是仅仅与图像和情绪坐在一起，即使你不能与图像坐在一起，或者你不知道它意味着什么，你一定感到非常害怕，这些事情正在发生，你知道，让我们坐下来，我们会坐下来。然后当你倾向于那种带有精神病的认知疗法时，会发生什么
happens is the person isn't going to listen to anything. They go off their medication. And they're not going to listen to anything that you have to say because they know that you're not respecting this part of them. And that's why the outcomes so much of the time are so poor for any kind of psychotic disorder. Yeah, you know, and I wrote about it in that book about James Hillman, what he told me one day.
事情是，那个人根本不会听任何东西。他们停止服药。而且他们不会听你要说的任何话，因为他们知道你没有尊重他们的这一部分。这就是为什么任何精神病障碍的治疗结果在很多时候都很差的原因。是的，你知道，我在那本关于詹姆斯·希尔曼的书里写过，他有一天告诉我的话。
He was never my therapist, what he told me one day. He was never my therapist, but he tuned in to what was going on with myself and my son back in 2004, I think. And he said, you know, his advice was, hey, you know, because I kept trying, I'd get embarrassed and I'd have things he'd say. And he said, you know, just quit trying to correct him, you know, just go treat him like a normal person. Nobody treats him normally. Of course, he doesn't want to go to therapies and wants to go on medication because he's not treated like a crazy person all the time. So just, you know, tell him about your life. And, and once I tell you, once I started doing that, it changed our relationship completely. So I've always be grateful to James Hillman for that. Just that one day of,
他从来不是我的治疗师，但他有一天调频到了我和我儿子在2004年左右发生的事情上。他说，你知道，他的建议是，嘿，你知道，因为我一直在尝试，我会感到尴尬，我会说一些话。他说，你知道，别再试图纠正他了，你知道，就把他当作一个正常人对待。没有人正常对待他。当然，他不想去接受治疗，也不想服药，因为他一直被当作疯子对待。所以，你知道，告诉他你的生活。而且，我告诉你，一旦我开始这样做，它就彻底改变了我们的关系。所以我一直很感激詹姆斯·希尔曼。仅仅是那一天，
of advice. And I, you know, I want to say for that, just that one day of advice. And, you know, I want to say about this, I mean, what is schizophrenia really? I mean, nobody really knows. And one thing about that I learned from my son is that he's in tune with other worlds. Yeah, it is such a relationship to the unconscious, such a wide gate, that you lose the ability to tell the difference between what's happening right now in the room with me, what I can imagine, what my emotions are symbolizing, and all this old genetic imagery. You can't tell the difference. You're just kind of in this collage of stuff.
的建议。而且，你知道，我想说的是，我的意思是，精神分裂症到底是什么？我的意思是，没有人真正知道。我从我儿子那里学到的一件事是，他与其他的世界保持着同步。是的，这确实是一种与潜意识的关系，一扇如此宽阔的大门，以至于你失去了区分当下房间里发生的事情、我能想象到的事情、我的情绪在象征什么以及所有这些古老的遗传意象的能力。你无法区分。你只是处于这种东西的拼贴画中。
And then people are telling you that it's bad, you know, and you're not, you're going to reject and have a negative reaction to that. Yeah, exactly. I mean, all of a sudden he would be drawing these geometric patterns and he would be writing in hieroglyphic symbols and where's
然后人们告诉你这是坏的，你知道，你会拒绝并对此产生负面反应。是的，完全正确。我的意思是，突然之间，他会画出这些几何图案，他会用象形符号书写，这些东西是从哪里来的？
that coming from? It is something very ancient. But they always have such a powerful intuition that is healing them if you get them in touch with it, you know? Exactly. And I think that, thank God, that actually was able to happen. I wouldn't have come to it myself, I don't think. But, you know, because in African cultures, other indigenous cultures, the shaman is often considered, the schizophrenic, so-called, is actually considered a shaman in often considered the schizophrenic so called is actually
这是一种非常古老的东西。但如果你让他们接触到它，他们总是有一种强大的直觉在治愈他们，你知道吗？完全正确。而且我认为，感谢上帝，这确实发生了。我想我自己是不会想到的。但是，你知道，因为在非洲文化、其他土著文化中，萨满通常被认为，所谓的精神分裂症患者，实际上被认为是一个萨满，在很多方面被认为是一个萨满，
considered a shaman in many ways because he can tune in he or she can tune in to things about people and situations that are really connected to ancestral forces, beings
因为他可以调频，他或她可以调频到关于人和情况的事情上，这些事情确实与祖先的力量、存在有关
perhaps that really exist that most of us don't acknowledge or see, but they do. And it forces a recognition in that way that, I mean, I'm so grateful for it. You know, it's something that I would never, as a rational investigative journalist, have come to. Well, I think that, like, the difference in more of a shamanic healing instead of the way that we conceive of medicine here,
也许确实存在，我们大多数人并不承认或看到，但他们确实存在。它以那种方式强迫了一种认知，我的意思是，我对此非常感激。你知道，作为一个理性的调查记者，我永远不会想到这一点。嗯，我认为，就像，萨满式治疗与我们这里构想的医学之间的区别，
and it's take a pill, germ theory, if this is wrong, then this is the thing that you do it. The way that shamanic healing works is that somebody who is out of control of their experience, you come in and you don't treat, you don't control, you just hold the experience for them. Yeah. And then they see you holding their experience and then they learn to hold their own experience. And that's and that's empowering.
那就是吃药，细菌理论，如果这里出了问题，那么这就是你做的事情。萨满式治疗的工作方式是，一个无法控制自己体验的人，你进来，你不治疗，你不控制，你只是为他们持有这种体验。是的。然后他们看到你持有他们的体验，然后他们学会持有自己的体验。而且那是，那是赋权。
That's what you need. And I think the people who I've met that have been damaged by being pulled out of the psychosis. It was that they were actually enjoying this thing and it's scary to the people around them, but something has kind of opened up, you know, and they're in this world and they're trying to figure out the experience. And all of a sudden you're pulled out of that, you know, with an antipsychotic, which, you know, has some benefits, too much psychosis. Jung said that the ego becomes perforated, that it can no longer kind of keep the unconscious at bay if it's been submerged too much. You know, now we have some evidence that there is damage to the prefrontal cortex. Too many psychotic breaks, you do start to lose overall functioning, which is why
这就是你所需要的。而且我认为我遇到的那些因为被从精神病中拉出来而受到伤害的人。是因为他们实际上很享受这种东西，这对周围的人来说很可怕，但某种东西已经打开了，你知道，他们在这个世界里，他们试图弄清楚这种体验。突然之间，你被抗精神病药物拉了出来，你知道，这也有一些好处，太多的精神病。荣格说自我变得穿孔了，如果它被淹没得太多，它就无法再阻止潜意识。你知道，现在我们有一些证据表明前额叶皮层受到了损害。太多的精神病发作，你确实开始失去整体功能，这就是为什么
it's important to recognize the prodromal period and get on the medication early. But, you know, the people who really were trying to heal themselves basically, and then the medication is pulling them out of that and had damage because they're not done, you know, and they feel like something's taken from them and they have this, um, you know, need to go back and confront it and integrate it. Um, and one of the, it's interesting with schizophrenia too. I mean, I'm not advocating for this, but you know, people will kind of heal themselves and age out of it. You know, there's a lot of risk to that. You're not advocating for that, but if you have a lot of wealth and money or you're kind of enabled, you know, John Nash is a, is a case for that. He, if I'm not really right, he never really took the medication.
识别前驱期并尽早服药很重要。但是，你知道，那些真正试图治愈自己的人，然后药物把他们从那种状态中拉出来，并受到了伤害，因为他们还没有完成，你知道，他们觉得有什么东西从他们身上被夺走了，他们有这种，嗯，你知道，回去面对它并整合它的需要。嗯，而且，精神分裂症也很有趣。我的意思是，我不是在提倡这一点，但你知道，人们会以某种方式治愈自己并随着年龄增长而摆脱它。你知道，这有很多风险。你不是在提倡这一点，但如果你有很多财富和金钱，或者你被某种方式赋能，你知道，约翰·纳什就是一个例子。他，如果我没记错的话，他从来没有真正服药。
He just kind of went around, um, you know, his Ivy league school until he slowly was like, oh, okay, I'm all right. And towards the end of his life, he school until he slowly was like oh okay i'm all right and towards the end of his life he said that psychosis was kind of a a retreat and an escape from these overwhelming forces of logic that he was trying to live in and he felt more integrated yeah that took 10 years you know that was that's a great story it's very true and yeah that's happened with with my son too i mean he's in his 40s now, you know. So he is. And James Huffman, too, told me that this often happens, that people age out, you know, not completely.
他只是四处走动，嗯，你知道，他的常春藤盟校，直到他慢慢地觉得，哦，好吧，我没事了。而在他生命的尽头，他说那种精神病是一种退缩，是对他试图生活在其中的那些压倒性的逻辑力量的逃避，他感到更加整合了。是的，那花了10年，你知道，那是一个伟大的故事，非常真实，是的，我儿子身上也发生了这种情况，我的意思是，他现在40多岁了，你知道。所以他是。詹姆斯·希尔曼也告诉我，这种情况经常发生，人们随着年龄增长而摆脱它，你知道，不是完全摆脱。
But I think that I've certainly seen that. And at the same time, Franklin's still very intuitive, you know. And I mean, I was amazed in the past of how he could read my mind, you know, sometimes. They understand. A lot of times, like really heightened intuition, they're not even really listening to what you're saying because they already know what you're thinking better than you do. You know, somebody says, I want this thing, but they know what you need.
但我认为我肯定看到了这一点。与此同时，富兰克林仍然非常直觉，你知道。我的意思是，过去我对他有时能读懂我的心思感到惊讶，你知道。他们理解。很多时候，就像高度发达的直觉，他们甚至没有真正听你在说什么，因为他们已经比你更了解你在想什么了。你知道，有人说，我想要这个东西，但他们知道你需要什么。
And then they end up in therapy and, you know, they end up doing therapy, you know, you end up making this podcast. But yeah, well, it's fascinating. I mean, it's also a very tough road. I will certainly say. And I wrote the book. The Left Hand Path is what Joseph Campbell called that journey. Yeah.
然后他们最终接受治疗，你知道，他们最终接受治疗，你知道，你最终制作了这个播客。但是，是的，嗯，这很迷人。我的意思是，这也是一条非常艰难的路。我肯定会这么说。我写了这本书。约瑟夫·坎贝尔称那段旅程为“左手路径”。是的。
Yeah. And I wrote the book because I wanted people to know, well, who could relate to the painful experience, but also could realize there are other ways of approaching this and other ways to look at it. And also even to find, you know, not necessarily a cure, but something that would be very helpful and useful in the kinds of ways that you're talking about as well. So I hope that that's the case. And yeah, the book, two editions came out, the paperback most recently one tells the whole story of our journey to Burkina Faso and as well as the earlier part. So I hope people will find it. I was always kind of struck when I was doing my early work
是的。我写这本书是因为我想让人们知道，嗯，谁能与这种痛苦的经历产生共鸣，但也意识到有其他方法可以接近它，有其他方式来看待它。甚至可以找到，你知道，不一定是治愈，但正如你所说的那样，在某种程度上非常有帮助和有用的东西。所以我希望情况确实如此。是的，这本书，出了两个版本，最近的平装本讲述了我们去布基纳法索的整个旅程以及早期的部分。所以我希望人们能找到它。当我做早期工作时，我总是被
in the similarity between people with schizophrenia and people with dementia, different kinds of dementia, because there are, there is this, they're not listening to what you say as much as how you, what you feel. And they don't remember what you say a lot of the time. They remember how you made them feel, you know? So, and it's like, put your jacket on, it's cold. You know, the dementia person just sees this anger and they don't like it. You know, but a patient with dementia, when you're just like, oh, it's okay, I'm putting my jacket on. Do you see that? You know, and then all of a sudden, you're just friends and what they're saying doesn't make any sense. But they're looking and smiling and you're walking and, you know, you can tell that they're going through this thing.
精神分裂症患者和痴呆症患者之间的相似之处所震撼，不同类型的痴呆症，因为有，有这个，他们听你说的不是那么多，而是你，你的感受。而且他们很多时候不记得你说了什么。他们记得你让他们感觉如何，你知道？所以，就像，穿上你的夹克，很冷。你知道，痴呆症患者只是看到了这种愤怒，他们不喜欢它。你知道，但是当你是，哦，没关系，我正在穿上我的夹克。你看到了吗？你知道，然后突然之间，你们只是朋友，他们说的话没有任何意义。但他们看着并微笑着，你们走着，你知道，你可以看出他们正在经历这种事情。
And, and we just treat both of those disorders wrong. You know, you go to like the Netherlands and different countries. And, you know, the places where people with dementia live is it's like, you know, there's a shopping, there's the fake supermarket with the plastic food and you get the card and you go through and you get it. None of it's real, you know, and then, you know, you go to the bed at night and they kind of have a routine. And here it's just like you're put into a cinder block elbow with fluorescent lighting and then you're given drugs because you're not sleeping at the right time and and you're not doing this, and then you're not bathing so people bathe
而且，我们只是错误地对待这两种疾病。你知道，你去荷兰和不同的国家。而且，你知道，痴呆症患者居住的地方，就像，你知道，有一个购物中心，有带塑料食物的假超市，你拿着卡，走过去，你就得到了。没有什么是真的，你知道，然后，你知道，你晚上去睡觉，他们有一种例行公事。而在这里，就像你被关进了一个带有荧光灯的煤渣砖房里，然后因为你没有在正确的时间睡觉而被给予药物，而且你没有做这个，然后你没有洗澡，所以人们给你洗澡
you. And then just the experience is traumatic, you know, for somebody who cannot advocate for themselves. But when you let them kind of have a more empowered and naturalistic thing, you know, the outcomes are so much better, and there's so much less trauma. And I think we do both of those disorders, just a huge disservice in the way that we treat them in mass here. Yeah. I couldn't agree with you more. And, and it's, it's tragic really for lots of families that that's, that's all there is. I mean, in the beginning, I didn't know if there was anything beyond, you know, just more and more medication of different kinds. I had no idea. I mean, that's what they're telling you. And
。然后这种体验本身就是创伤性的，你知道，对于一个无法为自己辩护的人来说。但当你让他们拥有更赋权和自然的东西时，你知道，结果要好得多，创伤也少得多。而且我认为我们在这里大规模地对待这两种疾病，简直是巨大的伤害。是的。我完全同意你的观点。而且，这对于许多家庭来说确实是悲剧，这就是全部。我的意思是，起初，我不知道除了，你知道，越来越多不同种类的药物之外还有什么。我不知道。我的意思是，这就是他们告诉你的。而且
well, this will help with this and this will help with the, you know, the more and more medication of different kinds. I had no idea. I mean, that's what they're telling you. And, oh, this will help with this. And this will help with the, you know, the depression. And this one will take care of the delusions and the paranoia. And then it just kind of becomes a deadening thing. I mean, because the person itself is trying to break through to something, you know, and to live a life that is connected. And yet they're reduced to that often. And it's, I mean, we went there, you know, and it's very tough.
嗯，这个会对这个有帮助，这个会对，你知道，越来越多不同种类的药物有帮助。我不知道。我的意思是，这就是他们告诉你的。而且，哦，这个会对这个有帮助。这个会对，你知道，抑郁症有帮助。这个会处理妄想和偏执。然后它就变成了一种麻木的东西。我的意思是，因为人本身正试图突破某些东西，你知道，并过上一种有联系的生活。然而他们往往被简化为那样。而且，我的意思是，我们去过那里，你知道，这非常艰难。
But there's, I'm just grateful that there's a reward on the other side, which is, you know, I talk, my son calls me all the time. We talk about what he's doing. He's always, you know, he's taking classes in welding and he's, you know, learning how to do's taking classes in welding and he's he's uh you know learning how to do various things with us he loves to work with his hands completely different than me i mean i work with my hands too and i just like so uh but he's he's involved in he has a shop out back where he builds all these unusual sculptures and so i don't always understand what
但是有，我只是很感激另一边有回报，那就是，你知道，我谈话，我儿子经常给我打电话。我们谈论他在做什么。他总是，你知道，他正在上焊接课，他正在，你知道，学习如何做，他正在上焊接课，他正在，你知道，学习如何和我们一起做各种事情，他喜欢用他的手工作，和我完全不同，我的意思是，我也用我的手工作，我只是喜欢，所以，嗯，但他参与了，他在后面有一个车间，他在那里建造所有这些不寻常的雕塑，所以我并不总是理解
it's about but i just so appreciate that that's who he's, he's become. Yeah. Well, and that's, that's beautiful. Thank you for, thank you for sharing. Um, I mean, I wish that we had, um, you know, infinite time cause you've written about so many topics, but it seems like the environment is a pretty big one. Um, you read a lot about ecology. Um, I was curious, have you, have you ever read any of the stuff like edge of the Sacred that David Tacey writes about depth psychology and ecology? You all seem similar in that. I have not read David Tacey on that, but I've read other, you know, like eco-psychology came to the fore when Hillman was alive. And he became very involved in it himself and wrote a book, or at least an introduction with Theodore Rozak, who was the scholar who founded that.
它是关于什么的，但我只是非常欣赏这就是他，他已经成为了这样的人。是的。嗯，那，那很美。谢谢你，谢谢你的分享。嗯，我的意思是，我希望我们有，嗯，你知道，无限的时间，因为你写过太多的话题，但环境似乎是一个相当大的话题。嗯，你读了很多关于生态学的文章。嗯，我很好奇，你有没有读过大卫·塔西写的关于深度心理学和生态学的《神圣的边缘》之类的东西？你们看起来很相似。我没有读过大卫·塔西关于那方面的文章，但我读过其他的，你知道，比如生态心理学在希尔曼活着的时候就走到了前台。他自己也变得非常投入，并写了一本书，或者至少与西奥多·罗扎克一起写了引言，他是创立该学科的学者。
So, yeah, he had his own, you know, very vital interest in ecology. And he was a gardener, you know, he was environment on every single issue and did two books on a book and then an updated version about climate change and the big moguls who knew everything about it 30 years ago and wouldn't do anything. Just covered it up. So, again, it's kind of exposing what's been hidden is what my one of my metier is. Yeah. Well, I mean, it's a different kind of applied depth psychology, you know, going in and seeing things other people can't see and bringing it out, you know. Yeah. And then I think what Hillman emphasized, too, was to take it personally in the sense of he gave this amazing talk in Italy in 1981 on the anima mundi, the soul of the world.
所以，是的，他有他自己的，你知道，对生态学的非常重要的兴趣。他是个园丁，你知道，他在每一个问题上都关注环境，并写了两本书，一本关于气候变化的书，然后是一个更新版本，关于那些30年前就知道一切却什么都不做的商业大亨。只是掩盖了它。所以，同样，揭露被隐藏的东西是我的职业之一。是的。嗯，我的意思是，这是一种不同类型的应用深度心理学，你知道，深入进去，看到别人看不到的东西并把它带出来，你知道。是的。而且我认为希尔曼也强调了要亲自参与，因为他在1981年在意大利做了一次关于世界灵魂（anima mundi）的精彩演讲。
And he felt that one of the big problems with conventional therapy is that all the emphasis is on yourself and your problems, what your mother did to you or your father. And there's so much wrong in the world that we can get involved in and apply psychological principles to. And let's go there. Let's turn our gaze that direction rather than just taking the inner into the outer and make that the soul's code or the soul's work. So, yeah, and I've tried to do that. I'm very involved in several personal crusades to save a fish, the Atlantic
他觉得传统治疗的一个大问题是所有的重点都在你自己和你的问题上，你母亲对你做了什么，或者你父亲做了什么。世界上有太多错误的事情，我们可以参与其中并应用心理学原则。让我们去那里。让我们把目光转向那个方向，而不是仅仅把内在带到外在，并使之成为灵魂的准则或灵魂的工作。所以，是的，我尝试过这样做。我非常参与几项拯救鱼类的个人运动，大西洋
striped bass. I wrote a book about that. And later in Mexico, the gray whales and this coral reef that was dying, and once you protected it, fish came back. It's not that big a jump. The striped bass came back. They were almost extinct. they were the greatest it was the greatest uh conservation success story in the world so it isn't even that we don't plan for it or understand it it's that we are planning for the problem that we're causing i mean i was reading that you know mitsubishi is designing these huge deep freezers
条纹鲈鱼。我写了一本关于那个的书。后来在墨西哥，灰鲸和那个正在死亡的珊瑚礁，一旦你保护了它，鱼就回来了。这并不是什么大跨越。条纹鲈鱼回来了。它们几乎灭绝了。它们是世界上最伟大的保护成功故事，所以甚至不是我们没有计划或理解它，而是我们正在为我们造成的问题做计划。我的意思是，我读到，你知道，三菱正在设计这些巨大的深冷冻库
to keep stuff perfectly intact for basically, you know, more than 50 years so that they can buy these enormous cattle size cuts of salmon. So that when I mean, it's not salmon tuna, so that when the tuna are extinct, you can still auction off million dollar,
为了让东西保持完美完整，基本上，你知道，超过50年，这样他们就可以购买这些巨大的牛排大小的三文鱼切块。所以当，我的意思是，不是三文鱼，是金枪鱼，所以当金枪鱼灭绝时，你仍然可以拍卖掉百万美元的
you know, blocks of sushi to these restaurants. And it's like, I mean, they're preparing for a fishery to be devastated and an animal to be extinct yeah that you could just not kill you know basically yeah isn't that the ultimate commoditization i mean projecting like that jeez i went to the some years back i was in japan for a whaling conference actually and went to the Skiji fish market where they bring all these, I mean it was one of the most horrible experiences, you know all these amazing beautiful
你知道，寿司块给这些餐馆。这就像，我的意思是，他们正在为渔业被摧毁和动物灭绝做准备，是的，你本来可以不杀它们的，你知道，基本上，是的，这不是终极的商品化吗？我的意思是，像那样投射，天哪，几年前我去过日本参加一个捕鲸会议，实际上去了筑地鱼市场，他们把所有这些，我的意思是，这是最可怕的经历之一，你知道所有这些令人惊叹的美丽
tuna that have been, were in there frozen up, deep frozen and ah I tell you and there aren't that many left in the water. We were just, it's appalling what we're doing to our our natural environment and the beautiful creatures that inhabit it. It pains me, and I think more people got to get involved. Yeah. Well, I kind of wish Hellman had lived long enough to see something like Brainspotting and also to live long enough to watch James Cameron's Avatar movies. It seems like that kind of paganistic that, that kind of, you know,
金枪鱼都在那里被冷冻了，深冷冻，啊，我告诉你，水里剩下的已经不多了。我们只是，我们对自然环境和居住在其中的美丽生物所做的事情是令人震惊的。这让我感到痛苦，我认为更多的人必须参与进来。是的。嗯，我有点希望希尔曼活得足够长，能看到像Brainspotting这样的东西，也能活得足够长，能看詹姆斯·卡梅隆的《阿凡达》电影。看起来那种异教徒式的，那种，你知道，
paganistic nature worship was something that he would really like the way that this guy could mainstream it in a way that he couldn't. And also the brain spawning is just so much of the direct experience you see Hillman longing for, but kind of failing and getting the techniques to do, you know, archetypal psychology is conceived, but never defined, you know, and not even
异教徒式的自然崇拜是他会非常喜欢的东西，他喜欢这个家伙能以他无法做到的方式将其主流化。而且Brainspotting也是希尔曼渴望的那种直接体验，但他有点失败，没有获得做这件事的技术，你知道，原型心理学被构想出来，但从未被定义，你知道，甚至没有
really practiced, you know. Yeah. Yeah. Well, there's, like you're talking about, applications of the ideas that you're working on, and I'm sure others are too. And I think that's fantastic because that's the future, right? Take the concept that was created that harkens back in time to the Renaissance and the Greeks. And then you move it forward into a way that maybe people in our age can benefit.
真正实践过，你知道。是的。是的。嗯，就像你谈到的那样，你正在研究的想法的应用，我相信其他人也是。而且我认为这太棒了，因为这就是未来，对吧？采用那个回溯到文艺复兴和希腊时期的概念。然后你以一种我们这个时代的人可能受益的方式将其向前推进。
Well, you know, and I think, you know, insurance comes in in the 80s and academia gets corporatized and healthcare gets corporatized and they just say, we're not going to mess around with trying to feel anything. We're basically just going to give some people ego management strategies and psycho education and call it cbt and if that doesn't work give them a pill and that that's what we do and now the pendulum is swinging the other way where these companies are like wait a minute maybe paying for band-aids for an entire lifetime is not as good of a strategy as just going and healing the wound and now we're more interested in trauma and somatic psychology and the body brain you know the you know the the beneath language part of us is what is causing trauma so just talking about
嗯，你知道，我认为，保险业在80年代介入，学术界被企业化，医疗保健也被企业化了，他们只是说，我们不会费心去感受任何东西。我们基本上只是给人们提供一些自我管理策略和心理教育，称之为CBT（认知行为疗法），如果那不管用，就给他们一颗药丸，这就是我们所做的。现在钟摆正向另一个方向摆动，这些公司开始意识到，也许为一个人终身支付创可贴的费用，不如直接去治愈伤口来得划算。现在我们对创伤、躯体心理学和身体大脑更感兴趣，你知道，我们内心深处那种超越语言的部分才是导致创伤的原因，所以仅仅谈论
and analyzing it is maybe fun or connects you to your therapist or helps you relationally but it doesn't help you get the stuff out of the body and regulate the stuff and cognitive therapy is fine you know it's like sailing a boat but the best person who the best sales person cannot um or not salesperson the best sailor cannot sail a sailboat through a hurricane okay you got to clear the water first before you can build those skills yeah and it's frustrating to me because i mean i'm not kidding it's the same authors it is the same doctors on these research papers that for years are laughing at you and saying none of this is evidence-based and you know cognitive behavioral therapy is the gold standard just which they say that just because it's easy to research it because you can turn every part of it into a number
并分析它可能很有趣，或者能让你与治疗师建立联系，或者在人际关系上有所帮助，但它无法帮你把那些东西从身体里排出来并进行调节。认知疗法很好，你知道，这就像驾驶帆船，但最好的销售人员——或者说不是销售人员，最好的水手——也无法在飓风中驾驶帆船。好吧，你必须先清理水域，然后才能培养那些技能。是的，这让我感到沮丧，因为我是说真的，这些研究论文的作者和那些医生，多年来一直在嘲笑你，说这些都没有循证依据，你知道，认知行为疗法是黄金标准，他们之所以这么说，只是因为它很容易研究，因为你可以把它的每一部分都变成数字。
because there's no room for intuition and there's no trust for the clinician and there's no room for the patient's experience um because you can turn everything into a number they research a lot and then they're like oh wow the only thing we researched looks like it researched pretty well. They're writing these papers about Jung and the unconscious is not real and repressed memory doesn't exist. And this idea of somatic psychotherapy and mindfulness space, whatever is not as effective as medication and that there is no unconscious. And then now they're publishing this stuff to get on them this new academic trend. And they're all like, oh, there's three kinds of memory,
因为这里没有直觉的空间，没有对临床医生的信任，也没有患者体验的空间，因为你可以把一切都变成数字。他们做了很多研究，然后他们说，哦，哇，我们研究的唯一东西看起来研究得相当好。他们写这些关于荣格的论文，说潜意识不是真实的，压抑的记忆不存在。这种躯体心理治疗和正念空间的概念，无论是什么，都不如药物有效，而且根本没有潜意识。现在他们正在发表这些东西以赶上这种新的学术潮流。他们都说，哦，有三种记忆，
primary, secondary, and tertiary. And secondary and tertiary are beneath the cognitive, or implicit memories inside. It's like, oh, you mean the fucking unconscious. Yeah, really. Right, right. No, that's fantastic fantastic that is great to hear because making the one day i'm gonna drink enough red wine to write them an email but uh i try and
初级、次级和三级。而次级和三级是在认知之下的，或者说是内在的隐性记忆。就像是，哦，你是说该死的潜意识吗？是的，确实。对，对。不，这太棒了，听到这个真是太好了，因为总有一天我会喝足够的红酒给他们写一封电子邮件，但我试着
stay off the radar of the people who control the boards in the profession so well that's good i'm glad you can because otherwise you know i mean let's face it who's making money off a lot of these therapies is uh is the pharmaceutical industry that uh you know, I mean, let's face it, who's making money off a lot of these therapies is the pharmaceutical industry that, you know, is making billions of dollars and they don't give a damn. I mean, well, maybe some of them do, but I don't want to totally judge the industry. But in general, it's not right. That's the entire emphasis.
远离那些控制行业委员会的人的视线。好吧，那很好，我很高兴你能做到，因为否则，你知道，我的意思是，让我们面对现实吧，谁在从这些疗法中赚钱？是制药行业，你知道，我的意思是，让我们面对现实吧，谁在从这些疗法中赚钱？是制药行业，你知道，他们赚了数十亿美元，他们根本不在乎。我的意思是，好吧，也许有些人会在乎，但我不想完全评判这个行业。但总的来说，这不对。这就是整个重点。
And we need to, I think think what's happening we're beginning to explore making the unconscious conscious you know in new ways and uh and that's going to help a lot of a lot of people get to what's what what they need there's a lot of um one of the things that's like sad to me is there's it happens like in the kind of the the uh not quite new age but a lot of the men's movements and kind of like depth psychology movements in the 80s and then in the 90s about technology um but you go back and you listen to these recordings of people and stuff and they're all like oh the ideas of depth psychology are being permeating culture and it's going to take over politics and there'll be a new political reality and we're going to be able to get you're listening to it in 2020 just like uh i'm so sorry i'm glad you're dead
我们需要，我认为思考正在发生的事情，我们开始探索以新的方式使潜意识意识化，你知道，这将帮助很多人得到他们所需要的。有很多，嗯，让我感到难过的一件事是，它发生在某种程度上，不是完全的新时代，而是很多男性运动和80年代以及90年代关于技术的深度心理学运动中，但你回去听这些人的录音之类的东西，他们都说，哦，深度心理学的思想正在渗透文化，它将接管政治，将会有新的政治现实，我们将能够得到……你在2020年听着这些，就像，哦，我很抱歉，我很高兴你已经死了。
and then you've got uh you know with uh technology there was all this talk about like well you know the internet um is going to be this big force that's going to bring the truth to everybody because the government controls the news but when the internet you can just log on and get the truth directly then you people will use the truth to make better political decisions and politics will be fixed and it's like no people don't want to change their behavior we are machines built to not to insulate ourselves from change and so what the internet did was it let me log on and look up 500 data points to support anything that I wanted to believe.
然后你有了，你知道，随着技术的发展，有所有关于互联网的讨论，说互联网将成为一股巨大的力量，将真相带给每个人，因为政府控制着新闻，但当互联网出现时，你可以直接登录并直接获取真相，那么人们就会利用真相做出更好的政治决策，政治就会被修复。但事实并非如此，人们不想改变自己的行为，我们是被设计成不让自己免受改变影响的机器，所以互联网所做的就是让我登录并查找500个数据点来支持我想相信的任何事情。
You don't know what. Climate change is taking a bit of a stick in the hat. Wherever you want to go, you don't know what to believe anymore. So you go for things that reinforce your own prejudices in the first place. That's not really a thing, you know? Anyway, it's a
你不知道什么。气候变化正在受到一点打击。无论你想去哪里，你都不知道该相信什么了。所以你倾向于那些首先加强你自身偏见的东西。那并不是真正的一回事，你知道吗？无论如何，这
pleasure talking to you about all this and finding out more about what's going on today because I haven't been able to keep up with all that. And it sounds good to me what you're doing. Well, what's sad to me is that the people who know the trauma now are in the forefront of that. They don't know Jung. And the people who know jung don't know this so it's like i sound crazy to everybody which is you know probably my mission in life you know when you do color based therapy and eye movement therapy and whatever it's like i'm just kind of leaning into everyone's going to think i'm a crank unless they come in and actually try it but uh you know it's one needs the other you know we have this ability to treat trauma now but we don't we have such a poor ability to conceive it and you know there's so many people that are
很高兴和你谈论所有这些，并更多地了解今天正在发生的事情，因为我一直没能跟上所有这些。听起来你所做的事情对我来说很好。嗯，让我难过的是，现在了解创伤的人正处于前沿。他们不懂荣格。而懂荣格的人不懂这个，所以这就像我在每个人听起来都很疯狂，这可能是我的使命，你知道，当你做基于颜色的疗法和眼动疗法以及其他什么的时候，就像我只是倾向于每个人都会认为我是个怪人，除非他们进来并真正尝试一下，但你知道，一个需要另一个，你知道我们现在有能力治疗创伤，但我们没有，我们构想它的能力太差了，你知道有很多人是
excellent practitioners that do brain spawning somatic therapy and they're like i do a video or i do a podcast and they're like the worksheets we have for free on the side and like people are like well yeah but how did you get this? What did this come from? Who trained you in this? And it's just like, this is a hundred years old. You know, this is,
优秀的从业者，他们做大脑定位躯体疗法，他们就像，我做一个视频或我做一个播客，他们就像，我们免费提供的练习表在旁边，人们就像，嗯，是的，但你是怎么得到这个的？这是从哪里来的？谁训练你做这个的？这就像，这已经有一百年历史了。你知道，这是，
you know, you, you need the gestalt therapy. You need you, you know, to be able to conceive of this stuff because you're now messing around with implicit memory and you have no language for it. You don't know what it is.
你知道，你，你需要格式塔疗法。你需要，你知道，能够构想这些东西，因为你现在正在摆弄隐性记忆，而你对此没有任何语言。你不知道它是什么。
Yeah. You're calling it a trigger and trauma response or a, you know, trauma bond or a somatic, whatever. trigger and trauma response or a, you know, trauma bond or a somatic, whatever. And those are just so hollow, you know, it's such a poor description of the thing.
是的。你称之为触发和创伤反应，或者，你知道，创伤联结或躯体，无论什么。而那些只是如此空洞，你知道，这是对这件事如此糟糕的描述。
And the people that are like, well, how did you, so many people are like, what is this? What are you doing? And it's like, it's not mine.
而那些人就像，嗯，你是怎么，很多人就像，这是什么？你在做什么？这就像，这不是我的。
Like, I just know how to read, you know, and I'm curious. And I kept reading CBT and being like, this sucks. Like, I don't get it.
就像，我只是知道怎么阅读，你知道，而且我很好奇。我一直在读CBT，觉得这太烂了。就像，我不明白。
You know, like, I don't, I don't get it. You know, I don't know. If people want to buy the book, is there a place that they could buy it that would give you more of a cut? Is there, you know, just Amazon or, you know, any of the places? And we'll definitely include links to everything that you would like us to link to in the show notes, too. Yeah, thanks a lot. I guess Amazon is the place where everybody goes, including me these days, for shopping. So, yeah, it's available on Amazon. All my books are.
你知道，就像，我不，我不明白。你知道，我不知道。如果人们想买这本书，有没有一个地方可以买到，能给你更多的分成？是有，你知道，只是亚马逊，或者，你知道，任何地方？我们肯定会在节目说明中包含所有你希望我们链接的内容。是的，非常感谢。我想亚马逊是每个人，包括我这些天，购物去的地方。所以，是的，它在亚马逊上有售。我所有的书都有。
Skyhorse has been my publisher for the last, I don't know, 10, 15 years now. And they're really good, and you can order the book from them. Hopefully, you know, you can find it through your local bookstore or certainly order it through a local bookstore. Yeah, so it's The Life and Ideas of James Hillman. There's volume one, two, and three coming up. So, and then My Mysterious Son,
Skyhorse是我过去，我不知道，10、15年来的出版商。他们真的很好，你可以从他们那里订购这本书。希望，你知道，你可以通过当地的书店找到它，或者肯定可以通过当地的书店订购它。是的，所以它是《詹姆斯·希尔曼的生活与思想》。有第一卷、第二卷和第三卷即将推出。所以，还有《我神秘的儿子》，
which we've talked about today is available. I would urge people to get the paperback rather than the hardcover because it brings the story up to date if this subject is of interest to them. Do you release your books through Audible? Yeah, the publisher does that, yes. They do? Yeah, that's good. So much of the books that I'd love patients to read, the ones that they end up reading, are always the ones that are available on Audible because everybody is so busy and people, you know, that's just how they get their, their literature. Yeah. You listen in the car, you know, whatever. Well, they're working
我们今天谈到的那个，现在有售。我会敦促人们买平装本而不是精装本，因为如果这个主题对他们感兴趣的话，它会把故事更新到最新。你通过Audible发行你的书吗？是的，出版商会那样做，是的。他们做吗？是的，那很好。我希望患者阅读的很多书，他们最终阅读的那些，总是Audible上有的那些，因为每个人都太忙了，人们，你知道，这就是他们获取文学作品的方式。是的。你在车里听，你知道，无论什么。好吧，他们正在工作
all the time. It's, I don't think it's not liking reading. It's just the material reality is that you don't have the time to crack the book. Exactly. Is there anything that we don't get to that you feel like is important? You know, I really thank you so much for sitting down with us. It's wonderful to meet you. And if there's ever anything I can do, reach out. And just I really appreciate it. But is there anywhere that this doesn't go that you think is important or any way you want to? Gosh, I don't know. I mean, I think we've had a really interesting wide-ranging discussion with a lot of things that uh i've been through and are of interest to me and and uh psychology
一直都在工作。我不认为是不喜欢阅读。只是物质现实是你没有时间去翻开那本书。正是如此。有什么我们没有涉及到的你觉得很重要的吗？你知道，我真的很感谢你坐下来和我们交谈。见到你真是太好了。如果有什么我能做的，请联系我。我真的很感激。但是有什么地方是这没有涉及到的，你认为很重要的，或者你想以任何方式？天哪，我不知道。我的意思是，我认为我们进行了一次非常有趣、广泛的讨论，涉及了很多我经历过的、我感兴趣的事情，以及心理学
is certainly one of them depth psychology and and uh you know the diseases that strike people and so um so yeah it's great i really really appreciate it. And maybe we'll do it again at some point. Yeah. Yeah, we'd love to have you on if you want to come on with another topic. You know, you've got a body of work where we could have a whole nother conversation another time. But for now, please check out volume two and volume one if you haven't read it. You know, James Heldman, The Life and Times. Life and Ideas of James Heldman. Life and Ideas. And there are a lot of other books, too. I mean, on Amazon, it's pretty easy to sort by author.
当然是其中之一，深度心理学，还有，你知道，袭击人们的疾病，所以，嗯，所以是的，这太棒了，我真的非常非常感激。也许我们会在某个时候再做一次。是的。是的，如果你想带着另一个话题来，我们很乐意让你参加。你知道，你有一系列的作品，我们可以改天再进行一次完全不同的谈话。但现在，如果你还没读过，请看看第二卷和第一卷。你知道，詹姆斯·希尔曼，生活与时代。詹姆斯·希尔曼的生活与思想。生活与思想。还有很多其他的书。我的意思是，在亚马逊上，按作者排序很容易。
Scroll through and look at it. There's a lot of heart in all of Dick's books. And they can go to my website. I have a website, dickrussell.org. And that has my biography and all that kind of stuff on it. So I don't keep it up as much as I should. But anyway, it's there. Okay.
滚动浏览并查看它。迪克所有的书里都有很多心血。他们可以去我的网站。我有一个网站，dickrussell.org。上面有我的传记和所有这类东西。所以我没有像我应该做的那样保持更新。但无论如何，它在那里。好的。
Well, we'll link to your website, but anyway, it's there. Okay. Well, we'll link to your website and we'll link to your Amazon store. And then I thank you so much. It was a pleasure speaking with you. Thanks to you, Joel. Thanks a lot for having me. To fix under cancelling star Hermes and Aphrodite you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
好吧，我们会链接到你的网站，但无论如何，它在那里。好的。好吧，我们会链接到你的网站，我们也会链接到你的亚马逊商店。然后我非常感谢你。和你交谈很愉快。谢谢你，乔尔。非常感谢你的邀请。修复取消明星赫尔墨斯和阿佛洛狄忒你。这个剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。